mes chers amis comme directeur de
campagne je suis très heureux et fier
d'accueillir pierre henri dumont député
du pas de calais faustine malliard
conseillère régionale et colistière
natacha bouchart la maire de calais
daniel fasquelle député du pas de calais
et président de la fédération des
républicains du département notre tête
de liste françois xavier bellamy et le
président de notre famille politique
laurent wauquiez
je
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
bonsoir à tous merci beaucoup de votre
présence nous allons entendre les
différentes personnalités que j'ai
appelé dans la salle et nous
continuerons ensuite avec un discours de
notre tête de liste
françois-xavier puis de notre président
notre famille politique laurent wauquiez
mais j'appelle maintenant sur scène un
enfant de notre pays celui qui fut maire
de marck en calaisis de 2014 à 2017 et
qui est devenu depuis l'un des plus
jeunes et les plus offensifs députés de
l'assemblée nationale
vous pouvez ovationné pierre-henri du
monde
[Musique]
monsieur le président des républicains
cher laurent mesdames et messieurs les
candidats aux élections européennes cher
françois xavier cher faustine mesdames
et messieurs les parlementaires
conseillers régionaux départementaux
maires et élus
chers amis quel honneur et quel plaisir
oui quel honneur et quel plaisir pour
moi de vous accueillir si nombreux ici
dans ma commune de marck en plein coeur
de cette terre du calaisis au carrefour
de l'europe une terre du calaisis
réceptacle des désordres de notre
continent
à quelques kilomètres du royaume uni
terre promise pour ceux qui fuient la
misère et la guerre mais aussi piteuse
exemple d'incurie politique pour tous
les tristes chevaliers du chaos qui voit
dans le bric site une projection de leur
propre aigreur isolationniste aux seuls
détriment des français
bienvenue à vous cher laurent cher
françois xavier
chers amis militants des hauts de france
dans ce cas les i qui depuis longtemps a
fait le pari de la jeunesse de la
compétence du renouvellement à droite le
même pari que les républicains font
aujourd'hui pour ces élections
européennes avec toi français xavier
avec toi faustine et avec l'ensemble de
vos colistiers
[Applaudissements]
nous ici on croit en la jeunesse pas
parce que c'est un effet de mode mais
parce que la jeunesse en politique est
le seul moyen d'assurer la pérennité de
nos idées la transmission de notre
héritage le respect de nos valeurs nos
valeurs de travail de liberté de justice
sociale de responsabilité de fidélité
aussi est ici dans la patrie du général
de gaulle
là où il s'est marié à quelle échelle
natacha cette vertu de fidélité prend
tout son sens mes chers amis cette
campagne pour les élections européennes
ne fait que commencer
et pourtant tous veulent déjà vous
dicter votre choix
ne vous laissez pas berner ne vous
laissez pas tromper
ne vous laissez pas duper en politique
il n'ya jamais de fatalité il n'y a que
des idées du courage et des convictions
s'il y avait une fatalité en politique
jamais natacha bouchart on aurait pu
prendre la ville de calais à la gauche
en 2008
s'il y avait une fatalité en politique
jamais la région des hauts de france
n'aurait pu être comme ta région laurent
conquise de haute lutte
s'il y avait une fatalité en politique
jamais je n'aurais pu remporter cette
commune ce canton cette circonscription
tous ensemble réunis autour de toi
françois xavier
nous allons déjouer les pronostics et
nous allons montrer une fois de plus que
le peuple de droite se lève que le
peuple de droite n'est pas mort car le
peuple de droite se tient debout car le
peuple de droite et rassembler et que si
vous êtes si nombreux ce soir c'est
parce que vous savez vous aussi qu'il
n'existe aucune fatalité et que le 26
mai prochain nous allons gagner
[Applaudissements]
peu
nous allons gagner non pas parce que
nous insultons nos adversaires mais
parce que nous sommes convaincus d'être
les seuls à proposer aux français un
projet solide et cohérent un projet qui
permettra d'assurer notre sécurité de
préserver notre économie est de donner
aux courageux aux besogneux aux
valeureux les moyens de vivre de leur
travail
le seul projet qui permettra de refonder
l'europe et le rétablir la france nous
allons gagner aussi parce qu'ici dans le
calaisis
nous avons la mémoire longue nous
n'oublions pas qu emmanuel macron
ministre de françois hollande a laissé
couler la compagnie my ferry link le
pavillon français dans le détroit du pas
de calais ces marins et leurs familles
sans lever le petit doigt
ouais pour eux pour ces marins pour ces
familles la renaissance promise par
madame loiseau nous rejetons l'inaction
nous rejetons la fatalité nous rejetons
le statu quo car nous croyons dans une
europe puissance qui respecte tous ceux
qui la composent et qui leur assure la
prospérité
mais nous n'oublions pas non plus que
les drames humains successifs qui
s'abattent sur le calaisis amenant
d'ailleurs des flots de destin et rend
en quête d'un eldorado chimérique forge
notre identité et développe notre
résilience et nous n'acceptons pas nous
n'accepterons jamais que la famille le
pen fasse de la détresse des calaisiens
arguments politiques stigmatisant à son
seul bénéfice personnel toute une cité
fier de son passé et enthousiaste pour
son avenir
le calaisis n'a pas à subir
année après année les mêmes images les
mêmes histoires les mêmes violences
qui peut croire une seule seconde que
l'immigration irrégulière non contrôlés
pour être mieux arrêter sans une
complémentarité entre la force nationale
et la solidarité européenne sans une
double frontières charles laurent
efficace à la fois aux portes de
l'europe mais aussi aux portes de la
france
ne vous y trompez pas l'extrême droite a
besoin d'une europe déréglé affaibli
bloqué afin de prospérer une europe qui
résout ces problèmes
une europe qui stoppe l'immigration
illégale comme le proposent les
républicains et leurs partenaires
européens
ce sont des voix en moins pour la
famille le pen lors du dernier scrutin
en 2014
l'extrême droite a terminé en tête des
votes en france en 2019
leur slogan et on arrive mais ça fait
cinq ans qu'ils sont déjà arrivés et
pour quel résultat
ils sont les plus nombreux au parlement
européen mais jamais la voix de la
france n'a été aussi faible à strasbourg
ils sont les plus nombreux au parlement
européen mais jamais l'europe n'a
accueilli autant de clandestins ils sont
les plus nombreux au parlement européen
mais jamais l'europe nous a paru plus
déconnectés des réalités et cher ami ces
cinq dernières années à strasbourg l'ont
démontré une voie pour l'extrême droite
c'est une voix inutile pour la france
une voix inutile pour vous défendre une
voix inutile pour votre futur vous
l'avez bien compris aussi bien pour les
amis de monsieur macron que pour ceux de
madame le pen
ce qui compte pour eux ce n'est pas
l'avenir de notre continent
l'avenir de notre pays l'avenir de nos
enfants mais bien leur seul et unique
avenir politique
j'en veux pour preuve le break site et
ses conséquences le président de la
république depuis le palais de l'elysée
et madame le pen depuis le château de
montretout désir la même chose que les
britanniques sorte de l'union européenne
le plus vite possible et donc sans
accord qu'apporte pour eux qu'une sortie
de nos voisins sans accord signifie ici
sur les autoroutes du littoral des
dizaines de kilomètres de bouchons
polluant l'air que nous respirons
bloquant notre axe au quotidien de
circulation qu'importe pour eux que le
trafic transmanche soit détournée
ralenti ou affaiblis et que donc des
centaines d'employés du calaisis se
retrouvent demain au chômage qu'importe
pour eux que nos commerçants hôteliers
artisans doivent mettre la clé sous la
porte
qu'importe pour que nos marins pêcheurs
cher daniel se retrouvent du jour au
lendemain exclus des eaux territoriales
britanniques et perdent plus de la
moitié de leur zone de pêche leur
indécence ne mérite ni vos votes ni même
votre considération notre territoire du
calaisis n'a pas vocation à être à
nouveau la victime expiatoire des jeux
politiciens et des dessins personnels de
ceux qui à paris nous ont déjà trahi par
le passé ou qui utilisez votre malheur
afin de gagner des points dans les
sondages
au contraire nous les républicains nous
sommes élus ici à calais dans le
calaisis dans la ruralité
nous avons une candidate issue du
terrain faustin qui sera vous défendre
tout au long de ces deux dernières
semaines de campagne et plus tard au
parlement de strasbourg
tous rassemblés parlementaires
conseillers régionaux départementaux
maires élus sympathisants militants des
villes de la campagne jeunes et toujours
jeune nous sommes derrière toi françois
xavier
derrière toi laurent derrière toi
faustine pour ensemble le 26 mai
prochain
refonder l europe et rétablir la france
remercie
merci pierre henry tu as déjà commencé à
parler d'elle son adn et le militantisme
avec sa jeunesse et sa sincérité
elle représente aujourd'hui notre région
sur la liste portée par françois xavier
je vous demande d'applaudir et
d'accueillir faustine mallya
[Musique]
faustine apparemment tout le monde te
connaît déjà et ovationnent médine ou
pourquoi tu as décidé de s'engager dans
cette belle bataille
j'ai décidé de m'engager dans cette
belle bataille tout d'abord pour
défendre mon territoire
pour moi tout a commencé ici je veux que
tout continue ici mon territoire c'est
ma raison de me battre c'est de défendre
des intérêts des habitants
et c'est surtout dans cette élection
européenne de défendre deux sujets
puisque nous incarnons l'europe nous
sommes le plan de convergence à des
grands mouvements du monde et bien sûr
la problématique migratoire et le
mexique qui sont au coeur de cette
campagne m'engager pour mon territoire
et m'engager aussi pour ma famille
politique je suis des vôtres vous me
connaissez pas ce que je me suis comme
vous j'ai commencé à sa saison avec vous
et je me suis très fier j'ai toujours
été de tous les combats de la famille
depuis
et quand je vois cette salle quand je
vois ces jeunes qui sont derrière moi
qu'ils sont ailleurs sur tous les
territoires jeu c'est ce qui fait notre
différence avec en marche en marche n'a
pas d'ancrage
ils ne savent pas où ils vont parce
qu'ils ne savent pas d'où ils viennent
c'est toute la différence
ce qui nous fera gagner cette élection
c'est vous c'est les militants bravo et
merci faustine je sais que tu voulais
aussi salué les autres policiers qu'ils
sont dans la salle
bien sûr je souhaiterais saluer mais mes
colistiers présent ce soir évidemment
notre tête de liste cher françois xavier
lorent et mes colistiers ici présents ce
soir karine charbonneau également
vice-présidente de la région est
sébastien veille les sandrine dauchez
alors je ne sais pas où ils sont mais je
les salue qui peuvent se lever ils sont
présents vous pouvez les nommer les
encourager et surtout
[Applaudissements]
et gabriel mélanie également excuse-moi
gabriel nouvelle un peu sera également
[Applaudissements]
égayée briel bien sûr qu'ils ont ce
sujet du mexique en connaît un rayon
puisqu'il est inspecteur des douanes et
tu pourrais en apprendre beaucoup je
pense à monsieur maquereau en la matière
merci beaucoup juste je souhaitais vous
passez en message ce soir bien sûr c'est
très important pour moi de représenter
la région avec mes colistiers ce soir je
suis la première de la région sur la
liste mais c'est une autre un travail
d'équipé et à titre personnel je
souhaitais vraiment remercier trois
personnes bien sûr pierre henry et
daniel nos deux parlementaires du pas de
calais qui m'ont soutenu et je les
remercie de cette démarche est bien sûr
un mot particulier pour pour natacha
bouchart sans qui je ne serais pas là
aujourd'hui je suis fier d'être engagée
à tes côtés je suis en exemple pour la
politique et je veux te dire toute mon
toute mon affection et ma détermination
à mener le bon combat les municipales
avec toi les prochaines vous pouvez
l'applaudir
bravo et merci beaucoup à faustine que
vous pouvez encourager applaudir
merci merci beaucoup faustine je vous
propose maintenant de regarder sur vos
écrans une petite vidéo
la sécurité doit être une priorité
absolue pour l'avenir de l'europe et
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
j'attends de l'europe qu'elle qu'elle
lutte contre la menace islamiste qu'elle
protège nos frontières les républicains
font de la sécurité un enjeu majeur de
leur programme c'est pour ça que le 26
mai prochain aux élections européennes
je voterai pour les républicains
pour moi la culture européenne devraient
être réaffirmés et faire partie du
programme des républicains la pac
aujourd'hui elle représente une grosse
partie du revenu des agriculteurs
on a besoin d'une pac forte pour la
modernisation de nos exploitations
l'objectif c'est le soutien de nos pme
la préservation des savoir-faire rare
des savoir faire d'excellence pour
l'europe et pour la france
je voterai le 26 mai prochain dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour les
républicains
je pense vraiment qu'il faudrait inciter
tous les jeunes à partir en erasmus pour
découvrir la civilisation européenne et
c'est pour ça que je voterai pour eux le
26 mai prochain
les républicains des propositions
concrètes et c'est pour ça que le 26 mai
j'irai voter pour les républicains
aujourd'hui nous avons un besoin énorme
de reconquérir des parts de marché car
le marché intérieur et don n'est plus
suffisant pour les transporteurs
français
nous avons besoin de cette harmonisation
au niveau européen pour défendre le
transport et pour l'avenir du transport
routier français
l'intelligence artificielle et au
numérique font partie intégrante de nos
vies
la france et l'union européenne doivent
investir et soutenir massivement nos
entreprises et nos startups pour ne pas
qu'on se laisse dominer par une
concurrence d'autant plus omniprésente
de plus en plus féroce de la part de la
chine et des usa les républicains ont
des réponses concrètes pour l'europe de
demain
c'est pour cela que je voterai heller le
26 mai prochain aux élections
européennes
par la force de ses convictions et sa
détermination elle avait arraché la
ville de calais après 37 ans de
communisme
elle est ensuite devenue sénatrice tu as
fait le choix de redevenir maire pour se
battre contre les clichés
contre vents et marées contre les appels
d'air vous pouvez ovationné natacha
bouchart
foire à tout et à tout ça mon cher
laurent cher françois xavier sa première
fois que nous nous rencontrons bienvenus
cher daniel et cher pierre henry lé
député du pas de calais nous en sommes
très fiers
geoffroy et puis faustine que je
soutiens dans ce début de cette carrière
politique
et puis on a aussi ici plein d'amis en
fait plein d'amis la liste est longue et
je n'aurais pas suffisamment de temps de
mes cinq minutes pour pouvoir saluer
chacun mais je crois que c'est important
ce soir de pouvoir bien dire à chacun
que les élus présents ce soir qui sont
très très nombreux
donc ça me fait chaud au coeur de
pouvoir
eh bien vous revoir vous recroiser pour
ceux de la région part je côtoie un peu
plus souvent ça fait plaisir et pour les
autres ça marque aussi que tout le monde
n'a pas quitté le navire
vous êtes bien là présent
et moi je suis vraiment très heureuse
d'être parmi vous ce soir à moins de 15
jours de ce scrutin dans cette campagne
venir dans le calaisis
c'était un choix merci laurent merci
françois xavier
mais ce choix s'impose avec cette force
de l'évidence tant nous sommes le point
de convergence des grands mouvements
européens et internationaux
bien évidemment face à la crise
migratoire pour lesquelles vous l'aurez
bien compris je me bats et je me suis
battue depuis des années pour que calais
ne devienne pas un terrain de jeu pour
personne afin de respecter l'ensemble de
la population
et puis plus largement
aujourd'hui face aux grecs site et plus
largement avec mes amis conseillers
régionaux et et collègues vice-président
la région qui est bien évidemment en
première ligne si les conséquences de
ces sujets ont une portée nationale
c'est avant tout ici et pas ailleurs
dans notre territoire que le nous
subissons toutes les conséquences et que
nous devons les assumer nous les élus
mais aussi l'ensemble de la population
que je tiens et pour lesquelles je tiens
à rendre hommage ce soir pour avoir su
affronter avec beaucoup de dignité
l'ensemble des éléments et des
événements que vous avez pu voir à
plusieurs reprises à travers les médias
j'ai aussi toujours considéré
que nous méritions de faire l'objet
d'une attention de fête particulière
c'est vrai ingérable me dire et on l est
ingérable
et oui je suis comme ça c'est avant tout
la défense de ma population de mai
habitants de mon territoire de miami qui
fait que ce soir je suis vraiment très
heureuse de partager ce moment je suis
avec vous et pourtant je tiens à
remercier cette commission d'investiture
d'avoir soutenu la candidature de
faustine maillard qui représente aussi
symboliquement et physiquement calais et
le calaisis dans cette liste j'ai ce
regret et tu le sais laurent que n'ayons
pas pu dans cette région avoir une place
d'éligible mais pour autant je me bats
aussi pour que nous puissions faire le
plus haut score possible
je vous lis aussi passé au ces
différents messages sur la façon
d'appréhender et de gérer cette
situation unique en france par rapport à
cette crise migratoire c'est l'humanité
la fermeté qui vont toujours guider
l'humanité
c'est ce que la france doit à ses
enfants à ses femmes à ses hommes que la
guerre a contraint à quitter leur pays
à ceux qui dorénavant nulle part dans le
monde ne peuvent dire qu'ils sont chez
eux mais l'humanité
ce n'est pas accueillir ces personnes
n'importe comment en effet où est
l'humanité
lorsque certains associatif davantage
activistes politiques s'évertue à
maintenir ces familles dans des
conditions d'extrême précarité et je le
dis avec détermination nous avons le
devoir de dénoncer ceux qui sous couvert
d'intentions louables ne font que
démultiplier leurs efforts
pour capter l'attention médiatique sans
laquelle ils ne sont plus rien mes chers
amis ses valeurs humanistes sont
profondément ancrées dans l'adn de notre
famille politique mais aussi et surtout
à calais l'un ou wii s'est marié le
général de gaulle c'est là le coeur
battant de l'héritage du général de
gaulle elles sont notre fierté
ce qui nous séparera toujours toujours
du rassemblement national second pilier
la gestion du phénomène migratoire c'est
la fermeté cette fermeté c'est
poursuivre et condamner ceux qui rendent
perpétuellement coupables de délits en
s'introduisant dans le domaine portuaire
en s'introduisant sur le site du tunnel
sous la manche qui s'en prennent aux
forces de l'ordre
en agissant de la sorte et qui de fait
ne demande rien à la france
cette position que j'estime responsables
et équilibrés je me réjouis de la
retrouver dans le programme défendu par
françois xavier bellamy ses colistiers
puisqu'il comporte plusieurs mesures
concrètes susceptibles de maîtriser les
flux migratoires convergent vers
l'europe et je pense notamment à la
propice propositions visant à créer en
dehors de l'union européenne des centres
d'examens de demande d'asile
ai je fait également référence à celle
consistant à conditionner le versement
des aides au développement à l'octroi
des laissez-passer consulaire depuis
2016 le bric site place lui aussi le
calaisis au coeur de la question
européenne
grâce au grand professionnalisme des
acteurs économiques au premier rang
desquels figure le directeur de la
société d'exploitation du port le pdg du
groupe eurotunnel
les transporteurs notre territoire est
prêt oui quel que soit le cas de figure
que nous présenterons qui nous se
présentera à nous au lendemain du break
site le calaisis sera en mesure d'y
répondre car les différents dispositifs
nécessaires étaient en place dès le 29
mars dernier incertitudes quant à la
date de sortie qui nourrit d'inquiétude
les idées inquiétude très légitime et
malheureusement cette incapacité du
parlement britannique à réunir une
majorité autour d'un accord de sortie
négociée par teresa may plonge le
royaume uni dans une crise politique
sans précédent face à la chine aux états
unis
face au phénomène migratoire qui n'en
est qu'à ses prémices je le dis très
clairement
l'europe n'est pas une option et calais
le calaisis dans cette europe sont des
battants en tant que maire présidente de
l'agglomération vice-présidente de la
région
je défends notre territoire avec le port
le tunnel les zones de développement
économique nous sommes puissants et je
déploie un projet qui assure la
transformation également de notre bassin
de vie
la plaisance le front de mer le dragon
de calais portée par françois
delarozière
mes chers amis engagés depuis mes 16 ans
j'ai été de tous les combats de notre
famille politique je ne les jamais
renier
je ne les jamais trahi je n'ai jamais
quitté
c'est parce que je demeure profondément
attaché à ce que nous sommes à ce grand
parti qui porte en lui l'héritage du
général de gaulle de jacques chirac et
de mon ami nicolas sarkozy
pendant ces derniers dix jours de
campagne
cher françois xavier toi tu es
colistiers auront plus que jamais besoin
de chacun d'entre nous pour aller
convaincre les nombreux indécis qui
peuvent faire la différence pour ramener
à nous ceux qui seraient tentés par les
extrêmes où la tension
alors pour conclure d'ici le 26 mai
prochain
mobilisons nous aux côtés de nos
candidats appelons à voter fait revoter
françois-xavier bellamy pour refonder
l'europe et rétablir la france vive le
calaisis vive l'europe et vive la france
elle est courageuse a tenté droite vous
pouvez applaudir natacha bouchart
merci beaucoup alors rue saint jean
devant le chat bleu ou devant l'aqualud
lycée résister au mode macro nien dans
la ville où le président de la
république va voter et prend ses
quartiers d'été
lorsqu'il rentre à paris au siège
national des républicains il compte les
sous et il est content tellement bien
qui lui a redonné à notre famille
politique sa santé financière et donc sa
capacité d'action vous pouvez applaudir
daniel fasquelle
mais écoutez chers amis quel plaisir
quelle joie de vous retrouver ce soir
est de vous accueillir chers laurent
cher françois xavier dans le pas de
calais ici à marck en calaisis avec
pierre henri dumont bien évidemment avec
tata chat et avec l'ensemble des
militants du pas de calais nord je me
dois évidemment de citer fredricks à
bloquer notre secrétaire départemental
je vois pas une injection qui est notre
vice président avec les rangs rich et à
ne pas oublier notre trésorier
départemental clément huchette
voilà je voudrais saluer également les
nombreux élus qui sont ici les
conseillers régionaux je peux pas tous
les citer parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux les conseillers départementaux
en saluant tout partiellement maïté qui
est friscourt qui est à la tête de notre
groupe
le conseil départemental alors et maïté
et la voilà je vous demande aussi de
l'applaudir parce que les calaisiennes
et l'été la tête d'autres groupes au
département et j'aurais évidemment salué
tous les militants du du pas-de-calais
comme je disais à laurent ici ce ne sont
pas des militants sont des résistants
parce que le pas de calais c'est un
département très difficile qui a été
longtemps hébergé la première section
fédération départementale du parti
socialiste un parti sis qui s'est
effondré au profit du front national et
nous avions ici lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle faut quand même
le rappeler et bien les deux finalistes
qui ont voté dans les partenaires du pas
de calais marine le pen
emmanuel macron et avec pierre henry on
a eu des rejetons des deux familles face
à nous aux élections législatives
puisque et bien pierre henry a battu la
famille le pen et j'ai battu la famille
macron et ça s'est passé ici dans le pas
de calais et en quoi en être fier
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs comme je le disais
tout à l'heure alors en faut regarder le
chemin qui a été parcouru depuis
quelques années puisque aux dernières
élections municipales on à natacha
conserver bien évidemment qu'elle est
c'est vrai que tu as mené un combat
absolument formidables ici qui a fait un
travail de fond absolument incroyable
moi je ne suis absolument pas inquiet
pour les prochaines élections
municipales à calais mais on a aussi il
ya des amis qui sont arrageois ici
nathalie manuel conserver arras on a
repris saint-omer et tant et si bien que
et bien nous avons pris la présidence de
l'association des maires du pas de
calais moi qui milite comme natacha et
avec tata chaps munitions chez les
jeunes rpr n'a pas si longtemps que ça
natacha et bien jamais nous n'aurions
pensé qu'un jour dans le pas de calais
les républicains auraient la présidence
de l'association des maires du pas de
calais et aux élections départementales
on a doublé notre score on a pris la
région je salue la vice-présidente de la
région karine et à travers l oncle et
des conseillers régionaux peut-être
jean-michel thakoon quand même voilà qui
est le local de l'étape je sais du tout
particulièrement ainsi que françoise
dumont quand on se lance des numérations
comme ça le riz c'est toujours d'oublier
quelqu'un de se faire engueuler à la
sortie voilà maintenant qu'ils pardon
par avance tout ce que je n'aurais pas
cité et on a effectivement pris la
région et puis lors des dernières
élections législatives nous avons doublé
notre score alors que ce soit de bonne
augure puisque en fait c'est important
la réunion de ce soir puisque c'est
aujourd'hui que commence la campagne
officielle des élections européennes
bien c'est dans le pas de calais et
comme nous avons progressé depuis très
nombreuses et dans le pas de calais bien
j'en suis certain nous allons encore
progresser dans les quinze jours qui
viennent pour nous offrir une belle
victoire une belle surprise 26 mai
prochain
le salue également nos amis venus des
départements voisins puisque c'est une
réunion des hauts de france et en
particulier
sébastien huyghe président de la
fédération du nord des républicains
brigitte lherbier qui est sénatrice pour
lui dire aussi brigitte bien évidemment
et puis laurent le fera peut-être aussi
mais aussi salué la présence de
françoise hostalier qui a été député
nous avons siégé ensemble à l'assemblée
nationale la quête ministre
merci d'être présente et puis je veux
saluer également la présence de nos amis
des autres départements j'ai vu
notamment j'allais y venir à la somme et
qu'est ce que vous croyez moi je n'ai
pas oublié la somme je suis député de
circonscription qui voisine de la sones
mais laissez-moi aller les choses dans
l'ordre ne vous impatientez pas donc
bien évidemment j'y venais le
département du nord mais également la
somme qui est avec nous ce soir
et s'ils sont là l'aisne et l'oise mais
c'est vrai que c'est le département du
nord et de la somme qu'ils sont pas
actuellement présents ce soir merci
merci à vous tous parce que ça nous fait
chaud au coeur
et puis je salue bien évidemment les
colistiers de françois xavier
faustine bien évidemment pas encore
applaudir parce que c'est une belle tête
de liste on est fier d'elle faustin qui
est très courageuse voilà et ça fait
partie de ces militants qui sont là qui
tiennent la boutique qui ont toujours
été là moi je me souviens lors des
dernières départemental laurent on
s'était fixé comme objectif d'avoir des
candidats dans toutes les cantons il y
avait à saint-omer un canton
c'est vrai très difficile à prendre et
on avait beaucoup de difficulté à
trouver un candidat en étant réunion
bureau comité départemental qui faustine
nous a dit écoute daniel c'est pas
possible il faut absolument qu'on ait
des candidats partout
et bien moi je veux bien y aller donc
elle a été candidate tu avec l âge à
l'époque 19 ans 19 ans 20 faustine et y
est allé elle a fait un beau parcours
d'une belle conférence de presse je me
souviens et finalement à la fin un beau
score baisser sa fausse in my way et
bien elle est courageuse et mérite
parfaitement sa place sur ses listes
n'diaye d'avoir un bel avenir politique
notre famille politique et dans notre
département je le salue aussi les autres
colistiers parmi ses colistiers voilà
c'est lui est quelqu'un qui est venu de
loin
alors elle a pas mis ces moon boot et
ses moufles mais presque voilà ce
qu'elle est venue de nîmes et du gard
mais tu vois les hommes on a aussi un
beau soleil qui fait très beau dans le
pas de calais c'est léa boyer qui est
notre plus jeune candidate aux dernières
élections initiatives en france et qui
est maintenant candidat sur notre liste
et qui représente avec franck proust le
gard et nîmes bien quelqu'un je voudrais
aussi remercier parce que je trouve
comme monsieur loyal il absolument
formidable mais surtout il fait pas que
ça parce que c'est la cheville ouvrière
et on travaille ensemble dans
l'animation de cette campagne doit très
modestement comptant les sous lui c'est
plus facile dans les dépenses en voilà
mais à la fin on s'entend bien quand
même voilà mais pas trop voilà il est
très raisonnable c'est geoffroy didier
merci au froid alors pour ton amitié ton
application est ta connaissance des
sujets européens puisque tu es déjà
député européen alors laurent vraiment
un grand merci d'avoir choisi le pas de
calais je sais que tu peux pas aller
dans tous les départements et je le
disais tout à l'heure on te dois
beaucoup
parce que c'est vrai qu'après la défaite
à l'élection présidentielle élections
légistatives notre parti politique était
très très mal en point et on aurait pu
se retrouver dans la situation dans
laquelle est aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste et avec beaucoup de courage
fallait un peu de folie aussi tu as
accepté de relever ce défi d'être
candidat à la tête de notre famille
politique
et depuis tu fais un travail de fonds
énormes alors qui est pas toujours
visibles de l'extérieur mais moi qui
suis de l'intérieur je sais le travail
que tu fais l'énergique tuer la
reconstruction patiente de toutes les
fédérations jusque dans les
circonscriptions les déplace
tu fais en france et ce travail de fond
de fourmi il est en train de payer donc
un grand merci à toi laurent pour la
façon dont tu animes qui guérit notre
famille politique on te dois beaucoup
oui merci également à françois-xavier
bellamy qui a réveillé cette campagne
électorale qui a réveillé la droite
aussi on peut le dire qui a suscité de
plus en plus l'intérêt et l'attention et
qui vous allez l'entendre tout alors moi
qui l'ait déjà entendu à plusieurs
reprises qu'il ya un discours qui est
une formidable clarté qui s'adresse à
tous mais surtout qui revient aux
fondamentaux
parce que je pense que face à manuel
macron qui veut en permanence brouiller
les cartes
la droite ne peut retrouver sa place que
si elle revient à l'essentiel que si
elles reposent les bases c'est le
travail que tu as fait laurent c'est le
travail que fait à l'occasion cette
campagne françois-xavier bellamy nous
avons beaucoup de chance de t'avoir et
surtout bravo à laurent pour sa
clairvoyance escompte il a fait ce choix
ça n'a pas suscité immédiatement
l'unanimité c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
mais aujourd'hui c'est l'unité de notre
famille politique est en train de se
reconstruire à l'occasion de cette
élection c'est vous il ya des signaux
incroyable quand vous entendez michel
barnier qui nous a rejoint le maire de
reims que j'adore ma faim ya pas très
longtemps je me souviens à l'occasion du
11 novembre
je l'avais vu lé télévision il était
face emmanuel macron qui avait fait
cette espèce de tour improbable où il
mélange et le devoir de mémoire et une
comme une mini campagne électorale
je me souviens avoir vu le maire de
reims qui étaient là en transe devant
monsieur macron
aujourd'hui il annoncé qu'ils
soutenaient notre liste je pense que
c'est une bonne nouvelle dominique
bussereau qui revient vers nous il y en
a beaucoup qui sont en train de revenir
vers nous antoine ruffenach qui sorti de
sa réserve
me le disais tout à l'heure françois
xavier pour annoncer clairement alors
que c'est compliqué pour lui puisque
vous savez très bien quelle voir
philippe lui a succédé à la tête du
havre antoine rufenacht qui cet après
midi à des paroles fortes en faveur
notre liste tout ça c'est de bonne
augure
la famille est en train de se
reconstituer le rendu est en train de
gagner son pari et françois xavier qui
est en train de gagner ses élections
merci et bravo à tous les deux alors
j'avais prévu de vous parler de beaucoup
de choses mais je crois que je vais en
rester là parce que ce sont eux deux que
vous êtes venus écouter avant que
geoffroy didier s'approche de moi avec
des gros yeux
je vais aller à l'essentiel évidemment
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur
l'europe sur les erreurs mais vous en
parlerez très bien les fausses pistes
que sont les pistes que lens marine le
pen mais quand on voit la situation
l'angleterre mots qui très souvent en
grande bretagne puisque je fais comme
fiori partie la mission briques site
comment peut-on penser une seule seconde
que sortir de l'union européenne serait
un avenir en chanteur pour d'autres pays
mais qu'elle aille discuter avec les
ouvriers de dyson de bentley d'airbus de
toutes ces entreprises qui envisagent de
quitter la grande bretagne puis qu'il
risque perdre et qui vont perdre leur
emploi à cause de du bric site qui vient
discuter que les marins pêcheurs ici des
transporteurs qui souffrent directement
des conséquences de briques site vouloir
sortir de l'union européenne voire
casser la construction paille ça n'a
aucun sens c'est dans ce pays
dans ce département qui est un peu celui
de geoffroy didier si on est bien
compris puisqu'il a dit chez nous et
c'est tout le sais très bien que tu
évolues très bien que tu as raison de
sortir ici chez toi dans ce département
on a souffert de la première guerre
mondiale et deuxième guerre mondiale
pour appeler à marine le pen que
l'europe des coalitions jantes ait
rejoint à la télévision qui parlait
l'europe des coalitions attendu le rock
des coéditions c'est l'europe du xviiie
siècle c'est le 19e siècle c'est celle
qui a échoué il ya que la construction
européenne qui nous amener la paix la
plus longue période de paix qu'on ait
connu en europe depuis depuis très
longtemps donc comment vouloir casser
tout ça quand on voit que ce serait un
fiasco du point de vue politique et du
point de vue économique
quant à emmanuel macron ils nous
proposent plus d'europe qui ne marche
pas nous propose une europe qui serait
souveraine mais la souveraineté
européenne ses négations des
souverainetés nationales ce n'est pas ce
que veulent les français ce n'est pas ce
que veulent les europe 1 il nous propose
une europe plus technocratique avec une
bonne dizaine d'agents ça n'est pas ce
que nous voulons non plus nous propose
de nouveaux élargissements alors qu'une
europe à 28 on n'est pas capable de la
faire fonctionner surtout il ne parle
jamais de notre identité de nos valeurs
de la civilisation européenne et quand
ils en parlent ils on parle très mal
moi je suis et même à la l'oiseau
d'ailleurs quitté sur une liste
d'extrême droite quand elle est
étudiante en quatrième année de sciences
politiques elle était candidate sur une
liste et fresnoy tu savais pas que
tennis d'extrême droite nous prend
vraiment pour des imbéciles
dans le pas de calais on dit qu'on nous
prend pour des innocent voilà oui c est
je le pense je le pense je pense me rend
la somme aussi ont dit nos usines de
charbon donc ça va ouf je me suis
réconcilié classe homme tout va bien
donc
eh bien le mal à oiseaux elle a quand
même il n'y a pas très dans un livre
qu'elle a écrit il ya pas très longtemps
nous expliquer qu'elle était favorable à
la gestation pour autrui et qu'il
trouvait que le voile ce n'était pas un
problème
j'en ai assez de ces gens qui n'ont
qu'une conviction qui sont opportunistes
qui ne sont guidés que par l' envie
d'avoir un poste mais ça ça n'est pas
possible et on n'en veut plus voilà donc
la liste de monsieur macron elle est
faite de bric et de broc est faite de
gens qui ne sont absolument pas d'accord
entre eux et c'est n'est pas stade dont
nous avons besoin alors que l'europe est
en crise et leur que la france est en
crise on a besoin au contraire de gens
de conviction et ces gens de conviction
les à ce soir en face de nous alors pour
conclure il faut surtout pas se laisser
enfermer dans une fausse alternative
on voit bien que monsieur macron et le
complice de m le pen eymann le pen est
la complice de monsieur macron parce que
notre lycée est en train de percer
parce qu'on monte dans les sondages on
est parti à 8 % en a 14 15 parce que les
français nous écoutent à nouveau qu'est
ce que fait monsieur macron puisqu'il a
une liste tête de liste qui est nulle et
archi nul
un oiseau qui à chaque fois qu'elle
ouvre la bouche d'une bêtise quand on
sait que madame le pen en réalité n'a
pas non plus aux réalités d'arguments
vraiment convaincant sur l'europe
quand on sait que le parti en marche n'a
pas vraiment de programme
qu'est ce qu'ils font quand ils sentent
qu'ils perdent du terrain la semaine
dernière ils perdaient du terrain qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils veulent nous refaire
le match de l'élection présidentielle
ils veulent nous voler cette élection
européenne
et ça il ne faut pas laisser faire cette
élection européenne et doit parler
d'europe comme le fait françois-xavier
bellamy comme le fait laurent wauquiez
cette élection européenne il est là pour
envoyer des députés français qui seront
au sein du parlement européen défend les
intérêts de l'europe et la france et
c'est élections européennes c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler à tous que la
droite elle s'en sont encore là que la
vraie alternative ça n'est pas un faux
choix entre monsieur macro et madame le
pen
la vraie alternative elle est devant
vous elle est présente ce soir dans la
salle et c'est avec les républicains
nouveau centre nous allons à la fois pas
établir l'europe rétablir la france
merci à tous et en avant et en met le
paquet dans les jours qui restent reste
avec tôt daniel c'est vrai que grâce à
la chaleur de son accueil on se sent
très vite chez soi
ici daniel alors dans quelques minutes
vous entendrez celui qui a accepté de
reprendre le flambeau et de relever le
drapeau de la droite c'est à dire
laurent wauquiez mais avant je vais
accueillir celui qui fait peur à managua
zoé qui lui fait tellement peur qu'elle
refuse les débats télévisés face à lui
vous avez compris de qui il s'agissait
nous sommes très fiers de l'avoir pour
tête de liste et qu'ils soient ici
présents ce soir parmi vous fait une
ovation à françois-xavier bellamy
[Applaudissements]
m
jamie merci infiniment merci infiniment
merci pour cet accueil si chaleureux en
effet merci d'être si nombreux ici ce
soir pour partager ensemble cette soirée
est parlé de l'élection européenne qui
nous réunit ensemble et c'est déjà une
chance inouïe que vous soyez si nombreux
c'est déjà un grand signe d'espoir parce
que vous êtes là en dépit de tous les
scénarios qu'on voulait écrit d'avancé
vous êtes là en dépit du fait que ça
fait des mois qu'on vous explique que
cette élection est pliée d'évidence et
que le seul match qui compte c'est le
match entre monsieur macron et madame le
pen entre madame loiseau et monsieur
bardella et bien vous vous avez dit que
vous vouliez avoir le choix que vous
vouliez avoir un autre choix et le fait
que vous ayez pris de votre temps que
vous veniez parfois de loin
que vous veniez de tous les départements
de cette région montre à quel point non
tout n'est pas fait d' avance et
l'essentiel se joue dans les quinze
jours qui commence merci infiniment
d'être ici ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier en particulier
tout ce qui nous accueillent remercier
la mère de marc qui nous accueillent ici
ce soir et puis bien sûr
chère madame bouchard vous dire merci de
tout coeur pour votre présence pour ce
signe de confiance que vous nous avez
apporté pour les mots que vous venez de
prononcer c'est une immense joie d'être
ici à calais dans cette ville qui est le
coeur de l'europe le coeur de tous les
succès de l'europe et aussi de toutes
ses fragilités et c'est cela que nous
sommes venus partager c'est de cela que
nous sommes venus parler je voudrais
remercier tous les élus qui sont ici les
élus départementaux régionaux municipaux
cher daniel je ne me risquerai pas au
jeu géographique aux politiques
dangereux quelques vient de livrer mais
je voudrais leur dire de tout coeur ma
reconnaissance
ma reconnaissance aussi parce que je le
vois depuis le début de cette campagne
ils sont la force de notre famille
politique vous êtes aussi la force de
notre démocratie
cette démocratie elle vit et elle tient
par nos élus locaux par tous ceux qui
sur le terrain tous les jours
réparé le tissu social abîmé rapproche
ce qui est en train de s'éloigner
reconstitue une démocratie que la
défiance menace d'emporter c'est par
vous que notre pays tient et je crois
que nous devons vous dire et nous devons
trouver l'occasion de vous dire ce soir
notre reconnaissance pour tout le
travail que vous faites remercie aussi
nos parlementaires et on peut les
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier nos parlementaires
chère brigitte cher sébastien remercier
bien sûr pierre henry pour les mots
qu'il a prononcés
pierre-henri tuer le signe effectivement
que rien n'est jamais perdu d'avancé que
les seules batailles compères sont
celles qu'on n'a pas livré et pierre
henry je voulais te dire à quel point je
te remercie d'être la voix de cette
jeune génération avec d'autres qui
aujourd'hui au parlement font vivre
notre liberté par le caractère toujours
pugnace que tu montres à l'assemblée et
je crois que c'est aussi à travers vos
voix à travers la voix de nos
parlementaires que nous pouvons trouver
encore l'occasion de nous exprimer dans
ce nouveau monde qui se montre parfois
si souvent incapable d'écouter merci de
ce que vous êtes et de ce que vous
faites et enfin je voudrais dire un
immense merci tout particulier à daniel
bien sûr vous me le permettrais parce
que au fond on parle beaucoup de cette
campagne en disant qu'elle fait la
surprise mais si cette campagne
fonctionne c'est parce que beaucoup
travaillent dans l'ombre beaucoup avec
beaucoup d'abnégation ont accepté de
prendre tous les risques de porter
toutes les difficultés
une campagne c'est un engagement de
chaque instant notamment pour faire en
sorte que le nerf de la guerre soit
toujours disponible pour l'action qui
doit être menée et celui qui a accepté
de relever ce défi qui m'a proposé
spontanément alors qu'il est déjà
trésorier de notre famille politique
d'être trésorier de cette campagne c'est
daniel fasquelle et je crois que nous
devons lui dire un immense merci
je lui disais tout à l'heure je lui
disais tout à l'heure mais comment est
ce que tu fais daniel pour être sur tous
les fronts à la fois toujours avec la
même disponibilité toujours avec la même
bienveillance avec la même sérénité
est ce que j'admire infiniment chez toi
c'est ce sens de l'engagement qui te
fait investir autant face au rachat de
siemens par ji que sur la cause de
l'autisme que tu portes avec tant
d'ardeur
je crois que c'est ça qui fait la force
de nos parlementaires c'est ça qui fait
la force de nos familles politiques
et c'est ce que tu incarnes ici bien sûr
et je voudrais te dire encore merci et
puis bien sûr dans une équipe comme la
nôtre tu as eu tu as eu des mots bien
trop bienveillants daniel en disant que
j'avais réveiller cette élection je n'ai
pas réveiller cette élection c'est nous
qui l'avons réveillé
c'est nous avec toi laurent c'est nous
avec vous tous ici c'est nous aussi avec
tous nos colistiers et je voudrais leur
dire à quel point je suis heureux et
fier de pouvoir mener cette équipe
allait à à karim à sandrine à gabriel à
sébastien et bien sûr tout
particulièrement à faustine faustine
tuer la première avec laquelle nous
ayons créer des liens forts
nous nous sommes parlé plusieurs fois tu
m'a dit ton désir de voir cette terre
que tu représentes portée est représenté
dans cette liste et je crois que les
questions que vous rencontrez ici ces
questions européennes il faut qu'elle
soit en effet porté défendu tout au long
du mandat et je voudrais dire à tous mes
colistiers qui sont ici que cette liste
qui a été constitué par laurent cette
liste il faudrait qu'elles travaillent
ensemble tout au long des prochaines
années d'abord il faut que nous soyons
grâce à vous par votre action le plus
nombreux possible à rentrer demain au
parlement européen mais il faut aussi qu
avec vous tous avec geoffroy nous
puissions continuer de travailler tout
au long des prochaines années élus ou
non pour que cette liste portent
ensemble
l'action du mandat européen qui en fera
parti faustin natacha a eu raison de
dire à quel point c'était en effet
important nous travaillerons tous
ensemble pour porter les couleurs de
notre famille politique pour porter
aussi la diversité de nos territoires
qui doivent être représentés au
parlement européen parce que de fait
parce que le fait nous le savons bien
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins
l'europe est à la croisée des chemins et
notre rencontre de ce soir elles se
déroulent dans la joie de nous retrouver
tous unis mais aussi dans la certitude
et la gravité la certitude que nous
avons devant nous un choix décisif à
faire depuis le début de cette campagne
je l'entend partout en france partout où
nous allons
je l'entends monter cette défiance cette
défiance qui a produit le break site
elle existe aussi en france cette
défiance qui fait que tant
d'agriculteurs temps d'entrepreneurs
temps de salariés dans d'ouvriers ont le
sentiment que l'europe nous fragilise au
lieu de nous renforcer
bien sûr nous croyons à l'europe est
notre famille politique est engagée
comme jamais dans le travail européen
parce que nous croyons que l'europe est
plus nécessaire que jamais mais nous
croyons aussi que pour que l'europe
puisse nous renforcer dans la
mondialisation il faut la réorienter en
profondeur il faut refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france et voilà
le projet qui est devant nous et voilà
pourquoi il est nécessaire de rentrer
dans le fond dans les sujets concrets
qui préoccupent les français
il ne suffit pas dans cette élection de
dire qu'on est pour l'europe ou de dire
qu'on est contre l'europe
il ne suffit pas d'être du côté de ceux
qui sont les gentils progressistes du
côté de ceux qui sont les méchants
populiste cette politique de posture
cette politique d'idéologie cette
politique d' attitude politicienne
superficielles nous n'en pouvons plus
nous n'en voulons plus elle est en train
de tuer le débat politique et elle est
en train de tuer si nous n'y prenons pas
garde
ce débat européen dont nous avons
tellement besoin nous le voyons bien ils
se sont mis d'accord
[Applaudissements]
ils se sont mis d'accord pour vous voler
cette élection ils se sont mis d'accord
pour qu'on ne parle pas d'europe
ils se sont mis d'accord dans ce moment
pourtant décisif pour l'avenir de la
construction européenne pour qu'on ne
parle que de la question de savoir qui
va l'emporter de monsieur macron ou de
madame le pen est ce que c'est à la
hauteur des sujets est ce que c'est à la
hauteur des enjeux
est-ce que c'est prendre les français au
sérieux que leur faire croire que c'est
un match à deux qui représenterait
l'état de notre démocratie
si on additionne toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion et parfois il faut savoir les
écouter on verra que seuls 20% des
électeurs français qui serait capable de
voter seuls 20% des électeurs français
se reconnaissent de madame le pen ou de
monsieur macron 20%
eh bien nous nous voulons parler aux 80%
restants à ce que 80 % qui ne se sentent
pas représentés à ce 80 % qui sont déjà
dégoûté de ce match qu'on voudrait leur
imposer à ses 80 % de français qui
attendent des réponses concrètes à ceux
auxquels on ne parle plus parce qu'on
veut jouer ce match politiciens qui a si
peu à voir avec la beauté de la
politique
monsieur bardella est entré en campagne
en disant j'ai un grand rêve pour le 26
mai c'est de voir pleurer christophe
castaner on a les rêves qu'on veut dans
la vie et m'a même loiseau et rentrer en
campagne en disant mon but dans cette
campagne
madame loiseau et rentrer en campagne en
disant mon but dans cette campagne c'est
de battre le rassemblement national
madame le pen dit aujourd'hui notre but
c'est de battre monsieur macron monsieur
macron dit notre but c'est de battre
madame le pen et bien nous nous disons
que notre seul but c'est de résoudre les
problèmes des français
et on ne fera pas on ne fera pas reculer
la défiance qui monte partout simplement
en l'insultant
bien sûr nous ne croyons pas une seule
seconde à une politique qui consisterait
à prospérer sur la colère sans lui
apporter de réponse tu l'as dit pierre
henry
nous ne croyons pas non plus à une
politique qui consiste à culpabiliser
ceux qui doutent ceux qui s'inquiètent
ce qu'ils voient partout aujourd'hui les
fragilités de cette europe que nous
avons construite
ils attendent des réponses concrètes et
lorsqu'un agriculteur me regarde les
yeux dans les yeux et me dit aujourd'hui
je travaille comme un fou et je vis
comme un misérable je n'arrive pas à
gagner ma vie malgré la politique
agricole commune
j'ai l'impression que l'europe ne
complique la vie au lieu de me renforcer
lorsqu'un agriculteur me regarde les
yeux dans les yeux en me disant cette
europe là je n'y crois plus je ne me
sens pas la légitimité la responsabilité
le devoir de le traiter de populiste je
crois que notre devoir c'est lui
apporter des réponses et notre devoir
n'est pas de prospérer sur cette colère
qui monte notre devoir n'est pas non
plus de persévérer dans le déni de
réalité
notre devoir c'est de refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france de
refonder une europe dans laquelle plus
aucun agriculteur ne puisse se sentir
abandonnés une europe dans laquelle plus
aucun entrepreneur né le sentiment que
l'europe lui compliquer la vie au lieu
de le soulager une europe dans laquelle
plus aucun maire ne soient abandonnés
seuls face au poids de la crise
migratoire que nous n'avons pas su gérer
voilà notre devoir voilà ce qu'est la
politique est bien ce devoir là on
voudrait nous en priver cette politique
là on voudrait nous l'a retiré ce débat
si fondamental
on voudrait l'interdire et bien moi je
vous le dis nous allons déjouer les
pronostics et nous allons rendre à la
politique ses lettres de noblesse
et c'est vrai que le disait geoffroy je
suis frustré aujourd'hui de voir que ce
débat n'est pas possible nous avons
devant nous la liste dans marche qui
nous disait que l'europe c'était le
coeur de son projet est bien ce projet
il aura fallu attendre 15 jours avant le
scrutin pour qu'on puisse enfin le
découvrir c'était pour la fête de
l'europe parait-il c'était le 9 mai on a
beaucoup de chance que la fête de
l'europe soit pas tombé le 27 mai parce
qu'on n'aurait sans doute pas eu le
projet avant de voter en tous les cas
quinze jours avant le scrutin on a pu
enfin découvrir ce que voulait la
république en marche
on sait enfin à peu près quelles seront
ses alliés mais aujourd'hui nous avons
une tête de liste qui refusent de
débattre qui refusent d'échangés qui
refuse de dialoguer aussi plus
exactement elle n'accepte de dialoguer
qu'avec une seule personne avec monsieur
bardella et bien moi je dis qu'il y a là
un vrai problème démocratique et je
crois qu'on ne peut pas prétendre
sérieusement combattre l'extrême droite
quand on considère l extrême droite
comme le seul interlocuteur
démocratiques légitimes
moi je dis qu'on ne peut pas prétendre
on ne peut pas prétendre combattre
l'extrême droite quand on fait tout en
réalité pour la faire exister dans le
débat politique
nous avons un but c'est de répondre aux
problèmes des français c'est de faire en
sorte de retirer ce qui nourrit
aujourd'hui cette colère le problème de
l'europe ce n'est pas le bric site
le problème de l'europe ce n'est pas les
populismes le problème de l'europe c'est
ce qui nourrit le populisme
le problème de l'europe c'est ce qui a
suscité le break site et voilà ce à quoi
il faut s'attaquer
le problème de l'europe c'est cette
naïveté qui a trop longtemps durer sur
le terrain économique et commerciale
cette naïveté qui nous a fragilisés dans
la mondialisation
nous croyons que l'europe est nécessaire
et elle a inventé les outils formidables
qui peuvent nous permettre de garder la
place de nos pays dans le monde qui se
dessine
elle a fait l'euro elle a fait le marché
unique
mais ce marché unique aujourd'hui est
d'abord une proie et une cible au lieu
d'être un levier pour nous renforcer
au lieu d'être un acteur et nous avons
parfois l'impression c'est vrai disons
le dans cette crise que nous vivons
d'être les spectateurs d'un monde qui se
fait à l'extérieur de l'europe dans
l'histoire se joue à l'extérieur de
l'europe alors que nous avons tout pour
pouvoir agir en europe encore faut-il
sortir de cette naïveté nous avons
aujourd'hui en europe encore la naïveté
de croire qu'il suffit de montrer
l'exemple de l'ouverture pour que tous
les pays du monde nous imite le saviez
vous par exemple en union européenne 20%
du pib est représentée par les marchés
publics 20% de la valeur créée en europe
et fait des marchés publics eh bien ces
marchés publics sont ouverts à 95% aux
acteurs internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à être
ouvert ainsi les marchés publics
américains ne sont couverts qu'à 30%
les marchés publics canadiens à 10% les
marchés publics chinois 0%
comment est il possible qu'une
entreprise chinoise peut venir prendre
un marché public en france et faire du
profit en france alors que jamais une
entreprise française
même la plus compétitive même la plus
exceptionnelle ne pourra prendre un
marché public en chine
cette situation là nous ne pouvons plus
la supporter plus longtemps et nous
devons maintenant exiger de nos
partenaires commerciaux de tous ceux qui
veulent échanger avec nous une stricte
réciprocité
parce que cette réciprocité
cette réciprocité elle est la condition
cette réciprocité est la condition pour
que la compétition est un sens
nous croyons à la compétition nous
croyons à la force de nos entreprises
nous sommes patriotes
nous croyons à l'excellence de nos
savoir-faire est ici dans cette terre
des hauts de france
on sait ce qu'un ouvrier français est
capable de faire ici sur cette terre on
sait ce que nos entreprises sont
capables de produire 11 c'est la force
des savoir faire que nous avons su
transmettre actualisé on sait ce que la
france peut apporter au monde et ce dont
elle peut rayonner dans le monde de
demain
mais pour que la compétition est un sens
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous la meilleure équipe du monde
si elle rentre sur un terrain qui n'est
pas plat et dans laquelle l'arbitré ne
jouent pas le jeu
la meilleure équipe du monde perdra
forcément la compétition eh bien nous
sommes dans cette situation nous sommes
la première puissance commerciale au
monde et pourtant toutes les autres
puissances du monde nous dit aujourd'hui
leur loi il faut en finir avec cette
naïveté il faut en finir avec cette
impuissance et il faut assumer enfin que
le premier rôle de l'europe c'est de
défendre d'abord nos entreprises et nos
emplois et je rejoins
et je rejoins ici sur ce point ce que
vous disiez à l'instant le premier rôle
d'un maire c'est de défendre son
territoire est bien le premier rôle de
l'europe c'est de défendre les européens
il y as aux etats-unis 1 buy american
act
nous ne pouvons pas en vouloir aux
américains de défendre leur entreprise
et leur emploi aux états unis si vous
voulez acheter un bien
vous n'avez le droit de l'acheter sur le
marché international que si vous ne
l'avez pas trouver sur le marché
américain
eh bien pourquoi faudrait-il que nous
nous interdisions d'écrire un bail
européenne actes pourquoi faudrait-il
s'interdire de privilégier d'abord nos
entreprises de privilégier d'abord nos
savoir-faire nos acteurs économiques et
nos emplois pour ne plus subir cette
désindustrialisation qui a si durement
marqué le territoire où nous sommes
évidemment ce ne sont pas ceux qui ont
laissé couler mifare et link qui
pourront nous dire qu'il faut défendre
nos entreprises qu'il faut défendre nos
emplois
c'est la tâche de notre famille
politique et nous opposer à cette
naïveté
ça n'est pas seulement tourné la page d
or du passé c'est prendre la mesure de
notre responsabilité
si nous ne savons pas faire ses choix si
nous ne savons pas refondé l'europe
si nous ne savons pas faire entendre la
voix de la france en europe alors c'est
vrai le projet européen risque d'en être
durablement discrédité et il risque de
voir poindre de nouveau la menace de
nouveaux breaks site un mot peut-être
sur le bric side car c'est exactement de
cela qu'il s'agit
j'ai été très frappée dans les débats
que nous avons pu avoir où toutes les
listes se retrouvait dans ce débat
notamment sur france 2 que vous avez
peut-être eu le courage de regarder je
sais pas si vous avez eu le courage je
vois à vos rires nerveux que certains
ont peut être regardé en effet vrai je
ne sais pas si vous avez eu le courage
de regarder jusqu'au bout ce que c'était
quand même très long moi j'ai essayé
d'éteindre la télévision mais j'étais
dedans alors j'ai pas pu c'était très
long et parfois un peu confus et je
crois à la force du débat mais justement
c'est pour cette raison qu'il était
peut-être utile d'avoir des dialogues
plus plus personnel avec d'autres têtes
de liste pour clarifier les enjeux
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé sur cette
question du bric site c'était de voir le
caractère très idéologique du tour que
la discussion prenait et certains de
dire que les anglais avaient pris la
mauvaise décision d'autres qu'ils
avaient pris la bonne et certains de
dire qu'il fallait qu'ils leur vote
d'autres qu'il ne redoute pas
nous nous disons que notre rôle n'est
pas là notre rôle de parlementaire
européen notre rôle de parlementaires
français demain au parlement européen
c'est de défendre par tous les moyens
les intérêts des français et je crois
qu'il ya là un enjeu absolument crucial
nous avons vu lire l'irresponsabilité de
nos concurrents dans cette affaire de
ceux qui effectivement se sont réjouis
du bric sites comme s'il n'aurait pas
d'impact sur les plus vulnérables déjà
de ceux d'entre nous qui subirons
directement ses conséquences les plus
durs l'irresponsabilité aussi disons le
du président de la république qui a été
le seul dans le dernier sommet européen
a affirmé que tout était préférable y
compris une sortie sans accord à la
poursuite des négociations
nous nous disons très clairement que
rien ne serait pire qu'une sortie sans
accord que bien sûr ce feuilleton dure
depuis trop longtemps que bien sûr il
est nécessaire que les britanniques se
mettent d'accord qu'ils sachent se
mettre d'accord comme les européens
l'ont fait sous la conduite de michel
barnier dont le soutien nous honore en
effet sous la conduite de michel barnier
qui a su obtenir à chaque étape de la
discussion
l'unanimité des 27 états européens et
voilà comment l'europe avance il faut
maintenant que les britanniques puissent
répondre à cet accord mais rien ne
serait pire que de conclure cette
discussion est de rompre sans accord
parce que si une sortie sans accord
devait avoir lieu
c'est 50% de la pêche française qui
resteraient à quai c'est à dire des
dizaines de milliers de familles qui
seraient directement impactés un emploi
en mer c'est trois emplois sur terre si
un break site sans accord devait avoir
lieu c'est notre industrie qui serait
directement touchés parce qu'elle a
besoin de ce lien avec la grande
bretagne
c'est nos services de sécurité qui ne
pourrais plus travailler ensemble et
c'est donc une fragilité devant la
menace terroriste
une fragilité supplémentaire que nous
aurions à subir si une sortie sans
accord devait avoir lieu
c'est les agriculteurs qui verrait
arrivé soudainement sur le marché
français des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes des centaines de milliers de
tonnes de produits agricoles qui ferait
chuter leurs prix de leur propre
production
déjà durement éprouvé oui il y a quelque
chose d' irresponsable a prôné une
sortie sans accord les nous continuerons
au cours des semaines qui viendront car
cet enjeu est décisif de défendre à tout
prix une issue favorable pour cette
discussion mais tous vaudra mieux qu'une
sortie sans accord est notre seul et
unique but sera de prendre en compte
les intérêts des français et en
particulier des habitants de cette
région et de ce département
[Applaudissements]
sortir de la naïveté pour assumer notre
rôle dans la mondialisation c'est aussi
bien sûr faire face à ce grand défi
migratoire
car c'est seulement par cet équilibre
retrouvé que l'europe pourra offrir au
monde
lorsqu elle redeviendra un poumon dans
la mondialisation pour faire face au
défi environnemental
lorsqu elle acceptera de défendre ses
intérêts qu'elle offrira au monde de
demain cet équilibre qu'il a besoin de
retrouver cet équilibre il faut qu'il
soit aussi maintenu sur la question
migratoire il faut qu'il soit aussi
rétabli face à ce grand défi et ce grand
défi vous l'avez dit il n'est pas
derrière nous il est devant nous la
crise migratoire gabriel elle n'a pas
encore commencé elle n'a pas encore
commencé car le défi de la démographie
du continent africain est immense et il
est devant nous et si nous ne savons pas
maîtriser nos frontières nous allons
continuer de produire du malheur à
grande échelle malheur bien sûr pour nos
sociétés malheur pour nos sociétés déjà
si durement touchée par le poids d'une
immigration massive que nous n'avons pas
su réguler et que nous n'avons pas su
intégrer malheur pour nos sociétés qui
sont directement déstabilisés par ces
flux migratoires incontrôlés et vous
êtes mieux placés que quiconque ici pour
le dire
et pour en témoigner même alors aussi
disons le pour tous ces jeunes venus
d'afrique auquel des passeurs sans
scrupules temps le miroir aux alouettes
d'un eldorado qu'ils ne trouveront pas
s'il arrive en europe
vous l'avez dit chère natasha nous ne
pouvons pas opposer l'humanité à la
fermeté la première exigence du devoir
d'humanité c'est de maîtriser nos
frontières c'est de maîtriser nos
frontières pour faire en sorte que
soient vraiment accueilli ceux qui ont
besoin de notre aide
mais pour faire en sorte que nous ne
confondons pas ceux qui légitimement
sont éligibles à l'asile et ceux qui
viennent uniquement chercher un espoir
en europe où ils ne trouveront qu'une
impasse à ceux qui nous font de grandes
leçons de morale sur la question
migratoire à ceux qui nous parlent de
générosité et d'accueil
il suffit de leur demander venez porte
de la chapelle
venez dans nos centres villes venez
partout où s'entassent ces jeunes venus
d'afrique qui se retrouvent errant dans
un endroit où
ont déraciné et sans avenir venez bien
sûr à calais venez voir ce que signifie
ce que vous appelez générosité et qui
n'est que l'autre nom de notre
inconséquence venait à calais voir ce
que signifie le fait de ne pas maîtriser
ses frontières aujourd'hui le président
de la république semble redécouvrir que
le mot de frontière n'est pas un mot
tabou
c'est une bonne nouvelle je me souviens
d'une époque où quand nicolas sarkozy
parlait de frontières on l'accusait
d'être d'extrême droite
je pense que ceux qui prônent le no
border ceux qui veulent supprimer les
frontières devraient venir à calais voir
qu'ici on est contraint de mettre des
murs avec des fils de fer barbelés même
autour des stations services mais menthe
même autour des entrepôts quand on
abolit les frontières à l'extérieur
d'une réalité politique
on les multiplie à l'intérieur d'une
société et ses frontières se multiplient
pour fracturer notre espace commun pour
fracturer notre lien commun nous sommes
contraints de mettre des murs autour de
la tour eiffel quand on abolit les
frontières qu'on ne sait pas à les
maîtriser
en réalité on les multiplie par tous sur
un territoire commun et c'est ce qui est
en train de nous arriver aujourd'hui
nous ne devons pas nous ne pouvons pas
nous n'avons pas le droit une seule
seconde de nous laisser faire ces leçons
de morale qui consiste à nous faire
croire que défendre ses frontières
c'est manqué aux devoirs de générosité à
ceux qui nous parlent d'accueil et bien
demandons-leur de venir voir ce qu'ils
appellent vraiment l'accueil et qui
n'est rien d'autre que notre impuissance
qui devient tragédie pour ceux qui se
font piéger par cette fausse générosité
et je crois qu'il y a là un grand défi
européen
parce que oui l'ampleur du défi est
telle que nous n'avons pas le droit de
nous séparer entre pays européens
oui l'europe est plus nécessaire que
jamais disons leur disons le encore elle
est plus nécessaire que jamais pour
renforcer chacun de nos pays et non pas
pour nous laisser déposséder cher daniel
comme tu le disais par une sorte de
super état qui nous priverait de notre
expression démocratique
l'europe est nécessaire pour renforcer
nos pays face aux défis qu'ils
rencontrent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons une double
frontières nous proposons de mettre
autour de l'europe une vraie stratégie
commune pour défendre ensemble les
frontières extérieures de l'europe et
laurent reviendra sur ce sujet si
capitale mais nous proposons
simultanément que défendre ensemble ces
frontières de l'europe permettent à
chacun de nos états de maîtriser
sa politique migratoire et c'est ce qui
nous distingue aussi bien du
rassemblement national que de monsieur
macron le rassemblement national est
tellement idéologues tellement reposer à
l'europe qu'il a voté contre tout ce qui
pouvait permettre de renforcer l'europe
face aux défis migratoires
le rassemblement national a voté contre
l'établissement de contrôles
systématiques à l'entrée dans l'espace
schengen le rassemblement national a
voté contre parlement européen
le renforcement de frontex cette agence
qui lutte contre l'immigration illégale
par pure idéologie
j'ai été en grèce il ya quelques jours
j'ai rencontré les responsables de
frontex
personne ne peut penser sérieusement que
la grèce seul avec ses dizaines d'îles
pourra défendre sa frontière face aux
défis migratoires
oui il faut agir ensemble en europe mais
oui il faut agir ensemble en europe pour
définir une stratégie qui nous permette
non pas de gérer notre impuissance mais
d'y mettre fin gérer notre impuissance
c'est ce que propose monsieur mâcon
peut-être avez-vous entendu il ya
quelques jours
madame belloubet chez bfm tv a dit on
n'arrêtera pas l'immigration
pour le dire autrement les flux
migratoires sont une fatalité
les gens vont et viennent 10 et l on ne
peut pas les arrêter est bien bien sûr
que si car une politique qui ne sait pas
maîtriser les frontières c'est une
politique qui prépare la dissolution de
toute réalité politique une politique
qui ne sait pas maîtriser les frontières
c'est celle qui nous condamne à nous
trouver déposséder de notre souveraineté
démocratique c'est celle qui voudrait
imposer des quotas de migrants comme le
propose monsieur macron aux pays
européens
monsieur mâcon propose de sortir de
l'espace schengen les pays d'europe qui
n'accepteront pas de prendre sur le sol
un quota de migrants eh bien nous nous
disons que ce qui compte c'est pas de
déplacer des gens d'un pays à l'autre de
manière arbitraire et administratives
c'est pas d'imposer aux sociétés une
immigration qu'elles ne peuvent plus
intégré ce qui compte c'est de
construire une europe qui renforce
chacun de nos pays qui renforce nos
démocraties et qui permettent à chacune
de nos démocraties décidé selon ses
capacités d'accueil et d'intégration qui
elle peut et qui elle veut accueillir ce
n'est pas à l'europe de décider qui doit
rentrer en france
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
parlons d'une double frontières défendre
ensemble les frontières extérieures de
l'europe défendre pour cela les
frontières de la france faire en sorte
que la france garde comme tous les pays
d'europe
la maîtrise de sa politique migratoire
voilà le défi qui est devant nous
et de ce point de vue là ne vous laissez
pas prendre monsieur macro on parle de
frontières mais rien n'a changé vraiment
rien n'a changé comme on le dit par chez
vous grand diseux petit faiseux monsieur
macro on parle de frontières mais jamais
l'europe
jamais l'europe n'a accueilli autant
jamais la france n'a accueilli autant
d'immigration légale
l'année dernière ces deux cent cinquante
mille titres de séjour qui ont été
délivrés c'est l'équivalent de la ville
de bordeaux qui rentrent en france
est-ce que nous pouvons accueillir une
ville de bordeaux en france en un an
la réponse que nous donnons est simple
la réponse est non et pour une raison
fondamentale le défi prioritaire pour
nous il est d'abord d'intégrer ceux qui
sont déjà ici et auxquels nous devons
faire partager le sens d'un héritage
commune d'un héritage commun le sens
d'une culture commune
voilà ce qui fait au fond l'un des
aspects les plus cruciaux de ce défi
européen
être capable de redire qui nous sommes
de partager qui nous sommes de
reconstruire ce lien commun jérôme
fourquet a publié un livre récemment qui
s'appelle l'archipel français dans ce
livre il montre à quel point la france
est en train de devenir un archipel de
communauté qui s'ignorent les unes des
autres qui s'éloignent les unes des
autres
et bien si nous ne voulons pas que la
france devienne un archipel qui prépare
les tensions et les crises de demain
il faut relever cet immense défi celui
qui consiste à refaire le lien qui nous
unit et ce lien précisément il se joue
aussi pour une grande part dans ce débat
européen car l'europe est ce lien
l'europe n'est pas seulement un projet
ça n'est pas seulement une construction
administrative ce ne sont pas seulement
des traités l'europe c'est d'abord un
héritage c'est d'abord une histoire
c'est une civilisation
l'europe c'est ce petit miracle discret
de la naissance de la raison dans la
grèce antique au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ ce miracle par lequel des
hommes et des femmes des ide qui ne se
contenteront plus d'une explication
mythique et qu'ils veulent comprendre le
monde et qu'ils veulent exercer leur
esprit critique pour mieux comprendre et
mieux connaître exercer leurs logos le
pouvoir logique
qui devient dialogos qui devient un
dialogue politique c'est la naissance de
la démocratie et de l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au conseil
municipal de la plus petite commune
nous vivons en enfants de ces grecs qui
ont inventé la délibération collective
par laquelle nous écrivons ensemble
notre avenir plutôt que de le subir
nous sommes les enfants de cette
histoire l'europe
l'europe c'est le sens de l'égalité
devant la loi devant la respublica
devant la chose de tout ce qui fait
l'esprit latin et qui s'étend dans tout
le monde latin par l'action de l' empire
romain c'est ce qui fait que petit à
petit un mur et le sens de l'état que
nous voyons si souvent bafoués
aujourd'hui et si nous souffrons de voir
ce sens de l'état bafoués c'est parce
que nous sommes d'une certaine manière
les héritiers des romains l'europe c'est
la tradition latine et c'est enfin
pourquoi ne pas le dire et pourquoi
avoir tant tardé à le dire pourquoi
s'être refusé nous mêmes à la nommer si
longtemps l'europe c'est évidemment
aussi cette histoire de la tradition
chrétienne d'une tradition
une tradition qui a fait mûrir pour le
monde entier progressivement
difficilement le sens de la dignité
humaine le sens de ce qu'est l'humain le
sens de ce que l'humain a une dignité
singulière qui fait que non l'humain ne
s'achète pas ne se vend pas ne se
marchande pas et qui fait
qu'effectivement l'europe
sonora d'agir contre la gpa contre la
gestation pour autrui à la
marchandisation du corps le sens de la
dignité humaine qui nous anime encore
aujourd'hui on a voulu nous faire croire
que nommer ses racines
on me le disait encore ce matin dans une
émission de radio
on a voulu nous faire croire que nommer
ses racines était une entorse à la
laïcité
mais d'où vient la laïcité sinon
précisément du mot latin qui désigne
dans l'église chrétienne
ceux qui ne sont pas des clercs la
laïcité vient du christianisme lui même
et oui bien sûr nous sommes laïque et
oui nous croyons à la séparation du
temporel et du spirituel
et oui jamais la politique ne doit se
résoudre à n'être qu'une opposition
communautariste entre des valeurs que
chaque communauté partage et qui
s'opposent les unes aux autres
oui nous cherchons ce qui nous est
commun et le sens de ce bien commun qui
nous lie mais oui tout cela vient d'une
histoire et ce commun a une histoire et
ce commun c'est la civilisation qui nous
attachent les uns aux autres c'est
l'europe et il faut retrouver le sens de
cette civilisation si nous voulons
relever tous les grands défis de
l'avenir
le premier ministre nous a opposé
le premier ministre nous a opposé que
des racines ne font pas un projet ceci
me rappelait le mot qu'avait employé
emmanuel macron dans un discours aux
bernardins dans lequel il disait vous
savez moi ce débat sur les racines de
l'europe ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse disait-il c'est là ce n est
pas les racines vous savez toujours
cette histoire que le nouveau monde est
forcément meilleur que l'ancien que pour
construire notre avenir il faudrait se
détacher du passé que pour se projeter
vers le futur il faudrait se détourner
de tout ce qui nous a fait ce matin
nathalie l'oiseau avec laquelle j'ai eu
le privilège de débattre à condition
qu'il n'y ait pas de caméra ni de radio
ce matin at il eu l'oiseau me disais je
ne veux pas d'une france en noir et
blanc
quel mépris pour nos aînés quel mépris
pour ceux qui ont fait l'europe dont
nous héritons quel mépris pour toutes
ces grandes images en noir et blanc qui
sont effectivement ce qui porte l'europe
aujourd'hui quel mépris pour qu'on le
voit à travers la manière dans ce
gouvernement a traité les retraités ceux
auxquels nous devons temps et bien moi
je crois qu'effectivement
je crois qu'effectivement on ne devrait
jamais opposé le nouveau à l'ancien et
je crois que ce qu'il ya de meilleur
dans le nouveau c'est toujours ce qui
est reçu de l'ancien et je crois que ce
qui fait la force qui nous pousse à
aller de l'avant c'est toujours ce qui
nous vient parfois du fonds des ans et
je crois c'est vrai que toute personne
qui a un jour dans sa vie planter un
arbre c'est qu'on n'a aucune chance
d'avoir de la sève si on n'a pas d'abord
des racines
alors oui nous devons absolument pouvoir
rpt dire qui nous sommes parce que nous
avons devant vous une devant nous une
menace qui nous fait face et cette
menace un nom cette menace a un visage
cette menace c'est le communautarisme
qui gangrène notre société
cette menace c'est l'islamisme qui
menacent notre société et face à cette
menace il faut des réponses policières
et des réponses judiciaires c'est
absolument nécessaire
je m'étonne d'ailleurs que le mot
islamisme n'apparaissent pas une seule
fois dans le projet dans marche
face à cette menace il faut des réponses
d'une fermeté absolue mais à la fin nous
ne gagnerons la guerre contre
l'islamisme que si nous savons veut dire
qui nous sommes
parce que je le vois et je le dis comme
enseignant il y a aujourd'hui tant de
jeunes qui grandissent en france sans se
reconnaître de la france tant de jeunes
qui grandissent en europe sans se
reconnaître
héritier de cette europe si l'islam
radical prospère dans beaucoup de nos
quartiers c'est parce qu'il remplit un
vide que nous n'avons pas su habiter
si l'islam radical prospère c'est parce
que nous n'avons pas su donner à tant de
jeunes quelque chose à aimer nous
n'avons pas su leur donner la france a
aimé nous n'avons pas su leur donner
l'europe en héritage en disant cela je
n'excuse rien je ne pardonne rien de la
barbarie qui a fait tant de morts
mais je dis que si nous voulons être
intraitable devant cette barbarie
il nous faut d'abord offrir une autre
voie offrir un autre chemin et oui
disons le ensemble nous n'aurons pas
d'avenir si nous ne sommes pas capables
de nous reconnaître enfants de cet élan
qui nous précèdent qui nous dépasse
infiniment et qui nous relient tous
ensemble et qui fait notre force commune
on n'a pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin on n'avait pas besoin
d'être chrétien pour se sentir
profondément touchée en voyant brûler
notre dame de paris
et voilà ce qui fait le miracle d'une
civilisation partager ces pierres qui
date de près de dix siècles elles ont
quelque chose à nous dire
elle nous relient les uns aux autres
elles sont cet héritage commun qui fait
que nous ne sommes pas indifférents les
uns aux autres que nous ne sommes pas
des individus juxtaposés qui poursuivent
chacun leur intérêt que nous ne sommes
pas des communautés étrangères les unes
aux autres qui ne se reconnaissent rien
de commun oui nous sommes français
oui nous sommes européens et ceci fait
ce qui nous lie ce qui nous attache et
ce qui nous oblige les uns envers les
autres d'une manière définitive
alors oui il faut nous montrer à la
hauteur du moment dans lequel nous
sommes
soit l'europe changera soit l'europe
disparaîtra il nous faut refonder
l'europe pour pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'elle soit pour l'avenir encore
longtemps une force qui agissent dans le
monde et qui renforce nos pays plutôt
que d'être aujourd'hui cette cible qui
semble être passive devant toutes les
menaces et tous les défis de demain
oui il faut refonder l'europe et oui
nous croyons à l'europe
mais oui nous croyons que pour que
l'europe puisse peser il faut qu'elle
change en profondeur la manière dont
elle se construit oui nous croyons que
pour que la france puisse peser en
europe
il faut qu'elle soit représentée par
ceux qui portent la voix des français
d'une manière lucide est clair et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est si
important que demain nous soyons le plus
nombreux possible à entrer au parlement
européen non pas pour la droite ou le
centre qui sont unis dans cette campagne
avec cpnt d'ailleurs je salue frédéric
nihous qui est ici avec nous non pas
non pas seulement non pas seulement cher
laurent pour notre famille politique
nous le devons bien sûr à notre famille
politique et à titre plus personnel je
te le doigt parce que tu as fait ce pari
et j'espère que dans quinze jours
j'aurais pu démontrer avec tous mes
colistiers que nous avons été à la
hauteur du paris que tu as fait mais
nous ne devons pas d'abord à notre
famille politique
nous le devons à notre pays nous le
devons à l'europe parce que nous sommes
à la croisée des chemins
il nous reste quinze jours pour être à
la hauteur du défi quinze jours pendant
les années qui viendront je voudrais
avec tous mes colistiers être votre
porte voix au parlement européen mais
pendant les 15 jours qui viennent j'ai
besoin de vous j'ai besoin de votre voix
il faut que tous les jours vous puissiez
si vous êtes convaincu être aussi
convaincant il faut que vous puissiez
parler à ceux qui doutent parler à ceux
qui se sont éloignés de nous parler à
ceux qui me croient plus à la politique
parler peut-être aussi à ceux qui me
croient plus à notre famille politique
et leur dire qu'il est temps d'y croire
encore parce que si vous êtes là ce soir
c'est que vous avez envie d'y croire
encore et oui vous avez raison d'y
croire encore dans 15 jours nous allons
déjoué tous les pronostics
dans 15 jours nous allons offrir à notre
pays à notre europe la victoire que nous
lui devons
ce sera votre victoire nous vous la
devons nous vous la devront merci
infiniment de ce que vous pourrez faire
pour refonder l'europe et pour rétablir
la france
merci de votre confiance merci de ce que
vous allez faire merci de cette victoire
que vous aller conquérir cette victoire
c'est la vôtre
[Applaudissements]
resterez stress
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi je
vous disais qu'on a la chance de l'avoir
vous pouvez l'applaudir et battez vous
pour lui mes chers amis c'est grâce à
lui que nous sommes là ce soir par sa
patience par sa constance par sa
persévérance il est devenu aujourd'hui
le principal artisan de la reconquête
j'appelle laurent wauquiez
[Musique]
un grand merci à tous un grand merci à
tous vous savez une différence
fondamentale entre notre tête de liste
et la tête de liste en marche la tête de
liste en marche il la cache notre tête
de liste on est fiers de l'entendre
voilà et je suis fier surtout de ce qui
s'est passé dans notre famille politique
je suis fier de ce déclic qui a eu lieu
je suis fier de voir que semaine après
semaine
il ya un élan qui s'est reconstruit une
envie qui revenu je suis fier de ce qu'a
fait françois xavier avec le trio début
puis ensuite avec tous ceux qui sont
autour de lui quand les sondages nous
donner à 8% et que maintenant on est
selon les sondages entre 13 à 15%
conte et la liste qui a le plus
progressé depuis le début de la campagne
et je suis très confiant dans l'issue
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il ya une
dynamique qui nous porte
il ya quelque chose de profond qui est
en train de se jouer dans le pays et que
sous-estiment tous ceux qui voudraient
faire quoi au fond ceux qui cherchent à
nous dire c'est que c'est la réédition
du second tour de la présidentielle mais
ça n'est pas le troisième tour de la
présidentielle les français ont le choix
sur la table de vote
il n'y aura pas que deux bulletins
emmanuel macron est obsédé par une seule
chose son seul but c'est battre marine
le pen le seul objectif de marine le pen
c'est de battre emmanuel macron mais les
français ne sont pas là pour éliminer
cette fois ci cette fois-ci les français
peuvent s'exprimer en fonction de leurs
convictions et je dis à tous ceux qui
sont ceux qui sont attachés aux valeurs
de la droite et du centre
exprimez-vous par rapport à vos
convictions exprimez-vous par rapport à
ce que vous voulez pour la france
exprimez-vous par rapport à ce que vous
voulez pour l'europe
cette fois-ci vous n'avez pas besoin
d'éliminer cette fois-ci vous pouvez
choisir
choisissez la liste d'union de la droite
et du centre
et en matière européenne ici comment ne
pas mieux le comprendre comment ne pas
mieux comprendre ici à quel point ce que
propose tout à la fois marine le pen
emmanuel macron est une double impasse
le bric site ce qui est en train
d'emmener le royaume uni dans le chaos
ce que vous mieux que personne vous
savez parce que vous regardez ce qui est
en train de se passer ici de près mais
quand les britanniques ont voté ils ont
voté en écoutant exactement les mêmes
discours que ceux de marine le pen quand
les britanniques ont voté ils ont voté
pour des gens qui portait exactement lé
même idée que marine le pen et cela
aboutit exactement à la même chose c'est
la déconstruction de l'europe c'est la
déconstruction de l'euro je combats
marine le pen parce que je suis
convaincu que dans cette élection
européenne ce qu'elle propose pour la
france c'est une sortie de l'histoire
ce serait le pire choix pour notre pays
que la déconstruction de l'europe
c'est pour cette raison que nous nous
battons contre marine le pen dans cette
élection et natacha comme tu me le
disait si bien oui notre famille croit
dans l'europe
oui notre famille et pour l'europe oui
c'est notre famille qui a été à
l'origine de la construction de l'europe
mais l'impasse l'autre impasse c'est
celle d' emmanuel macron qui consiste à
croire que il faut toujours plus de
l'europe qui ne marche pas c'est celle
qu'il incarne comme dans la première
phrase
le premier mot de la première
proposition de son programme c'est taxer
toujours plus de l'europe de la
bureaucratie toujours plus de l'europe
des impôts toujours plus de l'europe des
normes toujours plus d'élargissement j'y
reviendrai
il n'a pas compris
que les français croient dans l'europe
mais qu'ils veulent retrouver l'europe
qui marchait ils veulent retrouver
l'europe qui fonctionnait ils veulent
que nous répondions l'europe
ils veulent une europe puissance qui
soit capable de faire le bras de fer
avec les états unis et la chine
ils veulent une europe qui soient
capables de nous défendre parce qu'elle
sait qui elle est c'est cette europe que
nous nous voulons retrouver
c'est cette europe à laquelle emmanuel
macron lui tourner le dos son seul
objectif c'est une fuite en avant
il croit que l'on peut construire
l'europe sur les décombres des nations
nous nous voulons une europe qui
s'appuie sur les états qui s'appuie sur
les nations qui s'appuie sur les
frontières
c'est une europe civilisation que nous
nous voulons
[Applaudissements]
pour mener cette fondation
j'ai voulu qu'on fasse confiance à une
nouvelle génération
j'ai voulu que cela puisse être françois
xavier qui tire notre liste parce que je
crois que la politique a besoin de
reprendre un peu de hauteur
je crois que la politique sabine
tellement avec ce qui change d'avis au
gré des sondages que la politique
s'abîme tellement avec ce jeu des
petites phrases ça fait du bien d'avoir
quelqu'un qui nous emmène vers le haut
vous savez françois xavier a évoqué ce
débat ce débat de france télévisions
chacune des têtes de listes étaient
sommés d'emmener un objet qui incarnait
sa vision de l'europe
et quand je les voyais les uns après les
autres
je me disais mais c'est pas possible que
la politique soit devenu ça on avait le
général de gaulle et pierre
mendès-france et maintenant on a ça la
tête de liste du rassemblement national
était venu pour incarner sa vision
profonde avec une passoire rouge
une autre tête de liste était venu avec
une paire de menottes sur lequel il
avait mis des petits autocollants jaunes
la tête de liste dans marche depuis n'en
voit plus dans les médias était avec des
piments d'espelette et nous notre tête
de liste était venu avec un livre et
qu'elle livre l'iliade d'homère c'était
quand même autre chose
merci françois xavier de tirer la liste
vers le haut avec des talents tout
autour de toi ils ont été évoqués venir
l'impact soit faustine les à karine tous
ceux qui sont ici il ya autre chose qui
me fait plaisir c'est le rassemblement
je déteste quand notre famille politique
se déchire et j'aime quand notre famille
politique se rassemblent et dans cette
campagne semaine après semaine notre
famille politique c'est rassembler et
elle s'est unie et comme je suis heureux
quand j'ai natacha à mes côtés qui est
non seulement une amie qui est une
compagnons de route mais qui à ce
caractère ingérable que j'adore natacha
ne change pas c'est parce que tu as
gérable que ce thème
et c'est parce que tu as j'ai rappelé
que tu a métamorphosé calais et j'aime
qu'il y à son côté pierre-henri qu'il y
ait daniel qui est tous ceux qui sont
venus de toute la région du nord bien
sûr avec sébastien et brigitte de la
somme avec alain qui est de ce côté là
avec les autres élus de la somme qu'ils
sont aussi présents tout le monde est là
et ça ça me fait plaisir et j'aime qu'il
y ait ce rassemblement et cette unité de
notre famille des républicains
le maire de reims le maire de nice le
maire de toulouse
ils sont tous venus et au fur et à
mesure de la campagne ils nous ont
apporté leur soutien pour moi c'est la
plus belle des récompenses c'est quand
notre famille est unie et rassemblée
parce qu'alors elle est invincible et
une unité que nous avons fait avec la
droite et le centre
parce que notre liste et la liste
d'union de la droite et du centre avec
les centristes hervé morin et une liste
que nous avons fait parce que je l' ai
voulu aussi parce que je n'aime pas la
façon dont on parle des chasseurs sur la
liste dans marche
je n'aime pas les propos inacceptables
de mépris qu'ils sont tenus par un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont sur
la liste dans marche et moi je n'oublie
pas que si l'on veut aboutir au respect
et l équilibre de la biodiversité
les chasseurs sont une composante dont
nous avons besoin comme les pêcheurs et
que eux connaissent la réalité de notre
milieu naturel
alors j'ai vu ce matin que le premier
ministre insultant la droite trocadéro
étonnant premier ministre étonnant
premier ministre et quand parfois je les
côtes où je le lis je me dis que
définitivement
il ne sait plus dans quel rue où ils
habitent il ne sait plus dans quel
quartier il habite
mais s'il ya une chose dont je suis sûr
c'est qu'en tout cas il n'est pas rive
droite
il n'est clairement pas ré droite
ce premier ministre explique donc qu'il
n'aime pas la droite trocadéro mais la
réalité c'est qu'il n'aime pas la droite
tout court la réalité c'est qu'il n'aime
plus la droite
il n'aime plus la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est la droite qui ne renonce pas
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro celle
qui était aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy
comme de françois fillon parce que c'est
la droite qui ne baisse pas la tête
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est la droite qui ne trahit pas
lui qui a rejoint emmanuel macron à
l'arrière d'une voiture conduite par
bella avec une couverture sur la tête
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est celle qui lui dit non monsieur
le premier ministre non monsieur le
président de la république ce que vous
faites ça n'est pas une politique de
droite
on n'est pas à droite quand on traite
comme ils l'ont traité les retraités de
france en leur prenant 8 milliards
d'euros
on n'est pas on n'est pas à droite quand
on est incapable en deux ans de faire le
moindre économie sur la dépense publique
et comme on est réduit d'une façon ou
d'une autre à prendre dans la poche des
français on n'est pas à droite quand
dans le programme de sa liste on ne
mentionne même pas l'islamisme et que la
tête de liste madame l'oiseau explique
que pour elle il n'y a aucune différence
entre le voile islamique et le fichu que
portaient nos grands-mères honte à celui
qui peut porter cela
on n'est pas à droite quand on fait
soutenir sa liste par cohn bendit et que
le numéro deux de cette liste est un
ancien ministre de françois hollande qui
s'est toujours opposé à toute régulation
contre l'immigration irrégulière
on n'est pas à droite quand on est
incapable de rétablir l'ordre semaine
après semaine et que celui qui est censé
incarner la fermeté est un ministre de
l'intérieur comme monsieur castaner dont
on a compris la réalité de ce qu'ils
inspiraient et enfin mes amis on n'est
pas à droite quand le directeur de
campagne de la liste en marche a osé
déclarer que bien évidemment dès
l'élection passée il ferait des
alliances avec les socialistes au parti
heureux au parlement européen et qu'ils
avaient l'intention de siéger avec les
socialistes
nous nous sommes à droite nous la droite
est de retour et je le dis à tous ceux
qui sont attachés aux valeurs de la
droite c'est le moment de vous exprimer
fait le choix de la seule liste qui
porte à la fois la conviction de
l'europe et les valeurs de la droite et
du centre dans cette campagne européenne
[Applaudissements]
l'europe l'europe
aviez sans doute le seul à vraiment
parler d'europe qu'est ce que c'est que
l'europe qu'on fait les pères fondateurs
quand ils ont choisi ce drapeau sur ce
drapeau ils ont mis les étoiles de la
couronne de la vierge
les étoiles de la couronne de la vierge
que fait le général de gaulle quand il
veut réconcilier la france et
l'allemagne aient jeté sur les fonts
baptismaux
les élans qui porteront ensuite la
construction européenne quels lieux
choisit-il ne va pas bruxelles ne va pas
à paris ne va pas berlin il va dans la
cathédrale de reims
il va dans cette cathédrale qui avait
été détruite par les allemands pendant
la première guerre mondiale et il montre
ainsi que cette origine de nos racines
chrétiennes et de notre histoire qu'il
va aller puiser la refondation de
l'europe
que vont-ils que font-ils
mais comment ne pas le voir
ils font évidemment un projet de
civilisation ce qui les hantent
c'est une question toute simple comment
assurer un avenir à ce que nous sommes
comment faire en sorte que ce que nous
avons reçu puisse ensuite être transmis
c'est cela qui les habitent
pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes là parce
que c'est la même question qui nous
hante
comment arriver à assurer l'avenir de
l'europe
comment faire en sorte que la voix si
singulière de notre civilisation ne se
perdent pas comment faire en sorte que
nous ne soyons pas forcé de changer de
mode de vie alors que nous ne le
souhaitons pas pourquoi êtes vous là
parce que nous aimons tous notre
identité notre culture notre
civilisation que nous voyons les menaces
la chine les etats unis l'islamisme le
danger de décrochage de notre économie
et que nous ce que nous voulons c'est
redonner un avenir et du souffle à cette
civilisation européenne et
françois-xavier le sol a parlé de cela
les autres parlent de bureaucratie les
autres parlent de commission européenne
les autres parlent de bruxelles les
autres parlent de l'union européenne
nous nous parlons de l'essentiel nous
parlons de la civilisation
nous parlons de notre identité nous
parlons de notre culture nous parlons de
nos valeurs nous parlons de ce que nous
aimons du fond de notre coeur parce que
nous savons que si cela est perdu tout
le reste
a perdu
[Applaudissements]
marc et je suis très heureux que notre
meeting se soit tenue ici dans le
calaisis
parce que le calaisis se sont pas
seulement des résistants ce sont des
guerriers parce que dans le calaisis
même quand tout semble abattu on ne
renonce jamais et moi j'aime qu'on
combatte ainsi en ayant la passion
charnelle de son territoire c'est des
choses qui me parle
marc marc ça veut dire la frontière une
civilisation qu'est ce que c'est d'abord
c'est d'abord une frontière il y à
quelque chose qui est à l'intérieur et
il ya quelque chose qui est à
l'extérieur
et bien mes amis je vous le dis dans
cette campagne
une de nos différences majeures par
rapport à la liste dans marche c'est que
la liste dans marche et pour
l'élargissement emmanuel macron a
expliqué qu'il fallait ouvrir l'europe
aux balkans il s'apprête à ouvrir les
négociations pour l'adhésion de
l'albanie l'albanie mes amis à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et il
est allé dire à bucarest qu'il fallait
que la bulgarie et la roumanie entre le
plus vite possible à l'intérieur de
l'espace schengen
c'est une folie dites le autour de vous
c'est une des raisons essentielles pour
lesquelles il ne faut pas signé de
chèque en blanc pour la liste en marche
nous notre discours est très clair tous
ceux qui sont sur notre liste signeront
mercredi une charte d'engagement dans
laquelle il s'engage à voter contre
toute décision qui aboutirait un
élargissement supplémentaire de l'union
européenne et il y a eu trop de pays
[Applaudissements]
et la deuxième et vous le savez ici
mieux qu'ailleurs
si on a des frontières c'est qu'il faut
les défendre la tâche est d'abord je
veux le dire je n'aime pas que qu'elle
est soit résumer à cela
calais c'est bien d'autres choses
qu'elle est c'est le dynamisme de ces
commerçants calais c'est un port qui
alors que tout espoir semblait perdu au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
et que tout était détruit a su
complètement se reconvertir quelle est
cette une de nos principales façade
maritime qu'elle est c'est la fierté de
tout les labels que tu as réussi à voir
est notamment très récemment
ce label du patrimoine calais c'est
ceux-là d'abord attention là dessus
parce qu'il ya la dentelle de calais
mais il ya surtout la dentelle du puy en
velay et ça c'est ma ville
et là je ne rigole pas mais mes amis
comment ne pas comprendre quand on vient
ici à quel point on s'est mis la tête à
l'envers
bien sûr les choses vont mieux et elles
vont mieux parce que natacha s'est battu
mais la france ça ne peut pas être ça
j'étais tout à l'heure dans l'entreprise
paul est une entreprise extraordinaire
fondée par le grand-père qui
transportait du charbon
développé par le père qui a fait dix
salariés transformé par le petit fils
qui a réussi à en faire une très belle
entreprise qui fait 70 salariés et qui
embauche je vous parlerai dans les
chances que j'ai eu avec une des
salariées et qui dit beaucoup de choses
pour moi de ce que nous voulons pour
l'europe mais il est obligé de se
protéger avec des barbelés il est obligé
d'avoir un gars de chiens il est obligé
de faire passer tout camion qui veut
ensuite prendre le tunnel où allait
prendre les bateaux dans le port à
travers un détecteur pour vérifier qu'il
ya pas un migrant qui a éventré les
choses et qui s'est pas cachée derrière
une caisse et c'est cela l'europe
ça ne peut pas être seul à l'europe et
le ministre de l'intérieur vient ensuite
ici en disant de toute façon il faudra
s'habituer à voir régulièrement des gens
qui sont ici et qui n'ont aucune raison
d'être ici
et bien je le dise ça n'est pas
acceptable ça n'est pas à la france de
faire le garde frontière pour le royaume
uni
le royaume uni qui gère lui même ces
demandeurs d'asile voilà ce que nous
devons exiger et oui comme
françois-xavier l'a expliqué nous nous
demandons que toutes les demandes
d'asile soit faite sur le continent
africain
parce que quand les gens sont chez nous
c'est trop tard c'est trop tard et la
deuxième chose on nous parle d'une
immigration familiale
mais il suffit de venir à calais pour
comprendre que ça n'est pas une
immigration familiale
il suffit de venir ici pour le
comprendre il suffit de comprendre que
cela n'a pas de sens c'est que ça n'est
pas la vraie générosité
natacha comme tu l'a très bien dit la
vraie générosité c'est la vérité la
vérité c'est celle qui consiste à dire
que l'avenir de l'afrique ne peut pas
être en europe l'avenir de la jeunesse
africaine doit être en afrique et nous
notre devoir c'est d'aider le
développement de l'afrique et de
demander en contrepartie que les pays
africains s'engagent à reprendre leurs
ressortissants qui sont entrés
irrégulièrement sur le continent
européen
ça c'est la vraie générosité l'avenir
est en afrique une civilisation ensuite
ce sont des projets communs nous ne
sommes pas pour l'europe des normes
nous ne sommes pas meilleurs pour que la
france rajoute encore d'énormes aux
normes parce que nous comme on croit
être plus intelligent de tous les autres
quand l'europe fait une norme les belges
prennent la plus simple les allemands
prennent la plus simple et nous nous
prenons la plus folle et les
britanniques eux à ce stade refuse même
de les appliquer c'est encore plus
simple pas les normes les projets
l'europe qui nous parlait pourquoi
l'europe ne fait d'airtel pas tous les
centres de recherche d'europe pendant
cinq ans pour les faire travailler sur
ce défi immense que sont les maladies
neurodégénératives et alzheimer
moi vous savez
j'ai une grand mère que je chérissais
plus que tout une grand mère qui m'a
élevé ma maman était tout seuls et
travailler cette grand mère elle était
belge parce que j'ai un quart de sang
belle vous le savez ma famille partie de
ses racines ici entre la belgique et la
france sur ce territoire du nord cette
grand mère elle a été emportée par cette
maladie et pour moi c'était une épreuve
terrible de la voir elle qui avait
tellement d'énergie tellement dynamisme
qui était si intelligente si brillante
et qui étaient emportées par cette
maladie terrifiantes au fur et à mesure
vous perdez le contact avec l'être cher
où vous avez l'impression qu'on vous
vole votre mémoire ce que vous avez de
plus précieux et qui normalement reste y
compris après la mort et où les derniers
instants sont des instants que vous
voudriez vive si intensément et dans
lesquels on vous prive de les changes
les derniers mots des changes que vous
pouvez avoir c'est une épreuve qui est
l'épreuve psychologique c'est une
épreuve morale et c'est une épreuve
physique aussi pour les familles qui
sont confrontées
c'est sans doute le pire fléau du 21e
siècle je rêverais que l'europe se fixe
ça comme on veut et qu'on puisse revenir
en disant vous voulez savoir à quoi sert
l'europe et ben l'europe asservie a
servi à vaincre la maladie d'alzheimer
et redonner juste ce repos ces dernières
minutes ces instants aux familles qui
ont été frappés par alzheimer que
d'ailleurs les gens qui partent soit
jeune ou avait pas ce que la maladie
d'alzheimer frappe sans distinction
ça c'est l'europe à laquelle je crois
c'est l'europe des projets
et l'autre europe que j'aime c'est celle
du travail le travail ici on sait ce que
c'est que le travail ici on s'est
toujours battu pour remonter la pente
quand tout semblait perdu
ici on est attaché à cette valeur dans
cette entreprise où j'étais il y avait
une femme qui a forcément respect
coralie elle avait perdu son job
elle est repartie sur un parcours
d'insertion commerçante elle avait été
ruinée elle était repartie m'a dit je
n'ai pas dans le bon créneau pas éclos
bonne associés j'ai tout perdu
elle est reparti tout en bas elle a
suivi un parcours d'insertion
elle a passé son cassese quand on est
une femme c'est pas facile et elle était
employée dans cette entreprise de
transport où elle était dans le hall
logistique et où avec son chariot elle
s'occupait d'organiser le stock est bien
cette femme elle a forcément respect
parce que pour une coralie combien y en
at il qui eux restent tranquillement
chez eux à vivre des prestations
sociales accumulés et à vivre de
l'assistanat
ça ça n'est pas le vrai sociale le vrai
social c'est celui de coralie le vrai
social c'est celui qui consiste à aider
les gens qui sont en difficulté parce
que tout le monde peut être en
difficulté mais leur tendre la main en
leur disant il faut se retrousser les
manches se sera pas facile mais on va
vous aider parce que le vrai sociales
comme le disait ma grand mère ça n'est
pas de donner du poisson mais c'est de
ré apprendre à pêcher
moi je ne crois pas au social par
l'assistanat je crois au sociale par le
travail
c'est ce social là que j'aime et dans
notre famille politique on est fier de
ceux qui travaillent on défend nos
entreprises
il faut re défendre la préférence
européenne pour nos entreprises et il
faut retrouver la préférence européenne
pour nos agriculteurs
il y a dans cette salle des agriculteurs
je veux le dire qu'on est fiers de ce
qu'ils font
la france a la chance d'avoir des
exploitations agricoles familiales qui
font du bon travail
arrêtons de critiquer nos agriculteurs
et retrouvons la préférence agricole le
gouvernement s'apprête à mettre des
boulets aux pieds nos agriculteurs et
ensuite importer de la viande du brésil
et d'amérique latine
bourré aux activateur de croissance et
on fait la même chose avec les céréales
ça n'a pas de bon sens ça n'a pas de bon
sens
[Applaudissements]
et la dernière chose mes amis avec
laquelle je voudrais conclure une
civilisation c'est une culture une
culture c'est précieux une civilisation
c'est fragile en ce moment vous le savez
il ya des gens qui veulent mettre à bas
tout ce que nous sommes tous que nous
portons parfois des gens qui sont nés
sur le sol français née sur le continent
européen et qui ont tourné leur haine
contre la france et contre l'europe et
nous ne faisons rien et dans son
programme la liste en marche n'évoque
même pas une fois le mot islamisme même
pas une fois quand on a fondé la
république française et qu'il ya eu la
laïcité
on a exigé de l'église catholique bien
des efforts pour s'adapter et elle les a
faits pour concilier la république avec
ce qu est l église catholique et
aujourd'hui nous avons face à nous un
intégrisme l'islamisme politique qui tue
qui abat et on ne fait rien nous nous
portons des revendications qui sont
claires pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un pacte européen contre l'islamisme il
faut prendre les vraies mesures
les vraies mesures ça veut dire d'abord
qu'il faut fermer toutes les mosquées
salafistes en europe
il faut fermer toutes les mosquées
la deuxième chose bien sûr qu'il faut
faire c'est que quentin imams prêchent
la haine il faut le mettre dehors parce
qu'un imams qui prêchent la haine il n'y
a aucune raison qu'ils restent sur le
sol français
arrêtons de laisser le travail de
propagande se faire à l'ombre de nos
mosquées et c'est un tort aussi parce
que quand on laisse ce travail-là ce
faire on laisse petit à petit les
musulmans modérés être obligé de baisser
le regard parce qu'on laisse les
intégristes prennent prendre la main sur
les quartiers ce n'est pas cela la
république ce n'est pas cela la
république
et la dernière chose là dessus les
djihadistes savez je suis allé à mossoul
parce que dans ma région nous avons un
programme de soutien aux minorités
chrétienne en orient
j'ai vu ce qui s'était passé là bas j'ai
vu cette ville qui a été rasé j'ai
échangé avec un père de famille qui
avait perdu tous ses enfants tous ses
enfants ses sept enfants qui avaient
aidé tué et massacré juste parce qu'il
n'avait pas la bonne religion
j'ai vu cet immeuble où les djihadistes
prenez ceux qui ne partageaient pas leur
religion leur mettez un sac sur la tête
et les précipiter diot du building pour
qu'ils agonise pendant des heures
ensuite en ayant le coup brisé
j'ai vu ce terrain de foot où il faisait
jouer des gamins de 10 ans pas avec des
ballons de foot avec les têtes de ceux
qu'ils avaient décapité cela mes amis
sont les atrocités qui ont été commises
là-bas et le président de la république
le gouvernement a accepté que 200
djihadistes reviennent en france
nous nous demandons une seule chose nous
ne demandons une seule chose que
l'europe créé un tribunal international
en irak que ce tribunal international
juge en irak
les djihadistes qu'il soit condamné en
irak et qu'ils restent en irak
ils ne doivent pas revenir en france ou
en europe
[Applaudissements]
et comment tout cela s'est passé ici on
est sur un territoire dans lequel je
suis sûr que bien des visages ici pour
et en témoigner on s'est construit avec
aussi des apports de population qui
venait d'ailleurs des gens qui venaient
de belgique qui venait de pologne qui
venait d'espagne qui venait du portugal
qui venaient d'italie qui venaient du
sud de la méditerranée et qui se sont
intégrés
elles se sont intégrées parce qu'en
arrivant elle disait à leurs enfants
nous venons ici pour travailler ne me
fait pas honte respecte les règles de ce
nouveau pays apprend dur étudie dur
apprend le français écoutent à l'école
et surtout comprend qu'à compter de ce
jour la france c'est ton pays voilà ce
qu'était l'extraordinaire histoire de
l'intégration française et que s'est il
passé
mais nous avons inversé ce devoir
d'intégration
nous avons cru qu'à cueillir l'autre cet
effet en sorte que c'était à nous de
nous adapter aux modes de vie de l'autre
au lieu de comprendre que c'est tout
l'un vers ce qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'il faut prendre par la main celui qui
arrive pour lui expliquer ce que sont
les règles
ce qu'est le mode de vie du pays dans
lequel il a choisi de s'installer ça
n'est pas à la france de s'adapter à
celui qui vient de l'étranger
c'est à celui qui vient de l'étranger de
s'adapter à la france sans c'est la
vraie intégration
ça c'est la bonne intégration
et bien pour cela mes amis il faut
retrouver la fierté de ce que nous
sommes
oui il faut faire en sorte que les
racines chrétiennes soirée inscrite dans
les traités européens
oui il faudrait enseigner l'histoire de
france dans nos écoles oui nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que l'on renonce à
faire par exemple un voyage de classe ou
à la cathédrale de reims parce que vous
avez des élèves qui vont expliquer que
ce n'est pas compatible avec leur
religion
oui on ne peut pas accepter que dans un
hôpital il y un médecin homme auquel on
dise qu'il ne peut pas intervenir sur
une patiente femmes même si elle est en
urgence vitale parce que ça n'est pas
compatible avec sa religion vous
explique son mari
oui on ne peut pas accepter en france
qu'une femme dans un quartier n'est plus
le choix de la façon dont elle s'habille
parce qu'on lui explique que la religion
l'obligent à se couvrir
ça n'est pas cela la france à chaque
fois que nous reculons sur un petit bout
de ce que nous sommes c'est une partie
de notre civilisation que l'on perd
pourquoi pourquoi mes amis pourquoi n'ai
jamais voulu renoncer sur la question
des crèches ce symbole qui semble en
apparence si anodin parce que les
crèches est un petit bout de ce que nous
sommes et qu'à chaque fois qu'on se
soumet à chaque fois qu on recule on se
perd je ne veux pas de cela alors
retrouvons oui dans cette campagne des
européennes la fierté de notre culture
ici vous êtes dans le calaisis ici c'est
ce site magnifique qui est au confluent
de la mer du nord et de la manche ce
site magnifique où commence la côte
d'opale où seuls ceux qui ne sont pas
venus ne pas pu se laisser ébahir par la
qualité extraordinaire de la lumière
dans les ciels qui sont traversés par le
vent moi j'aime cette côte d'opale parce
qu'elle dit quelque chose du dynamisme
de la pugnacité et de la beauté de la
nature quand elle est aussi authentique
ici c'est calais c'est un endroit qui a
souvent vécu les épreuves qui a marqué
l'histoire de france à travers
l'héroïsme de sa résistance face à
l'envahisseur anglais
les bourgeois de calais cela dit quelque
chose de ce qu'est l'esprit de la
résistance ici ici à calais plus des
deux tiers de la ville ont été plusieurs
fois mis à bas et jamais vous n'avez
renoncer
ici à calais comme dans ce territoire du
nord de la france des hauts de france
vous remontez toujours la pente même
quand tout semble perdu et bien j'aime
cela il n'y a pas de destruction
définitive il n'y a jamais d'espoir
définitivement perdu il n'y a jamais
rien qui ne peut pas être reconstruit
pourquoi est ce que nous avons décidé de
porter cet emblème refonder l'europe
rétablir la france parce que précisément
ici à calais plus qu'ailleurs
vous le savez on ne renonce jamais on ne
baisse jamais le regard on regarde
toujours vers la mer on regarde toujours
vers l'horizon et on arrive à déjouer
les pires tempêtes et les pires défaites
c'est cela ce que je vous demande de
faire
il nous reste 14 jours la reconstruction
de notre famille politique a commencé la
capacité à faire résonner à nouveau avec
fierté ce qu'est la voix de la droite a
commencé je suis convaincu que la france
et l'europe en ont besoin on peut
déjouer dans cette campagne tous les
pronostics
mais j'ai besoin de vous il ya quelque
chose qui a commencé aidez-nous dans ses
14 jours pour le transformer en un
mouvement qu'on n'arrêtera plus vive la
france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je